Ich sehe die ersten sind schon da, aber ihr wart schon da bevor der Stream on gegangen
ist oder?
So lange ist der Stream noch gar nicht on, müsst vorher da gewesen sein.
So und habe ich die Woche irgendwas verpasst?
Weil irgendwas spannend ist, ich überlege gerade, irgendwas, wo man sagen würde, das
hätte man mitbekommen müssen.
Mir fällt jetzt nichts ein ehrlich gesagt, es ist jetzt seit Wochen schon diese ganze
Twittergeschichte.
Na ja gut, was will man da großartig zu sagen, beziehungsweise juckt mich jetzt wenig.
Ansonsten war irgendwas, ich überlege gerade, war irgendwas spannendes die Woche?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe die Woche irgendwie in der News Screenshot gesehen, dass die Gasspeicher in Deutschland
jetzt bei 102% sind, wie auch immer das gehen soll.
Ich glaube da muss man jemand nochmal was mit Prozenten erklären, aber okay.
Kann auch sein, dass das Fake war, es war nur ein Screenshot.
Aber es war die Woche glaube ich nichts spannendes.
Also so, weltweit.
Technik, technisch, weltweit, war glaube ich nichts spannendes.
Trump wurde entsperrt, ernsthaft?
Ist jetzt?
Ist jetzt so, okay.
Mal zwei mal gucken.
Hat er schon was getweetet?
Nee, ich glaube das ist, ist bei denen nicht noch mitten in der Nacht?
Ja, Sleepgill.
Primo und Dankeschön für den Sub, 34 Monate Alter, es wird echt mal Zeit für neue Sub-Icons.
Also scheiße, 34 Monate, das sind jetzt ja quasi fast drei Jahre.
So lange bin ich schon am Start, wirklich ja.
Hab ich gar nicht dran erinnert, gut ich habe am Anfang mit dem Fabian ab und zu noch ein
bisschen BDO gestreamt und sowas, ist schon, ich glaube es ist noch länger, es ist noch
länger her.
Wo ich mit Streamson angefangen habe.
So wie wir beim Thema sind, man muss einfach anfangen.
Ja, 2017, das ist schon ein 5 Jahr, man muss einfach anfangen.
Das war Just Do It, ne sonst war glaube ich die Woche echt nichts spannendes.
Was macht dann, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob es irgendwas sinnvolles gibt, wenn wir gerade
schon früh am Start sind.
Deals for you to improve, was, nee, nee, nee, nee, Home Improvement, Tools und Home Improvement,
Home Improvement ist auch ein geiles Wort.
Computer and Accessories.
Gift Ideen, äh nicht Gift, Gift Ideen klingt ein bisschen verkehrt auf Deutsch.
Geschenkideen.
Ok, mal ganz schnell gucken, ob da irgendwas sinnvolles dabei ist, Moment mal, es gibt
mal einen Stuhl, nee, hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, kacke, ja, das ist auch teurer
geworden.
Leutnant Gizmo, moin, ja das ist ganz schön teuer geworden, 2000 Euro, so viel habe ich
ja bei weitem nicht bezahlt.
Ok, Crap, Crap, Crap, ist das alles das gleiche, egal was ich aufmache, Leute, jebaited, angeblich
unterschiedliche Kategorien, ist das alles das gleiche, jebaited von Bezos persönlich.
Deine Stromkosten steigen nächstes Jahr um 100%, meine ich auch, so ist irgendwas, ist
da irgendwas dabei, irgendwas, was mich sofort anspricht, sieht nicht so aus, nope, nope,
nope.
Apple, ok, der Hüllen, geil, irgendwelche komischen Handy Hüllen, als interessiert
mich das, ansonsten ist da nix dabei, Handy Hüllen, na super, geil, super gespart, easy,
nix.
Hat jemand von euch irgendwas gekauft, schon, von diesem ganzen Prime Week, was eigentlich
gar keine Week ist, und an dem Friday, der eigentlich auch jeder andere Tag und Friday
ist, 600 Euro, das waren die Uhren, yep, Glock, bald kommt der Black Friday im Monat, manche
machen das schon, du willst lachen, manche machen schon Black Friday im Monat, es ist
ok, es ist gar nix dabei, wir kommen jetzt eine Sache nochmal, wo manchmal bisschen was
gescheites dabei ist, es ist Lightning Deals, so, Rest ist aber alles Müll wahrscheinlich,
Aha, Socken, Air ABC, alles klar, Hosen, Powerbanks, irgendwelche WLAN Repeater, die
keiner braucht, Schuhe, was auch immer das ist, irgendwas zum paddeln, Gürtel, Handschuhe,
Jeans, Messer, Hosen, was auch immer, nur wenn man das anzieht, kriegt man dann so krasse
Muskeln, alles klar, Aha, Buba, Messer, Schuhe, meine Güte, es ist ja nur Crap dabei, hier
erkenne ich nicht mehr was das ist, Leute, was soll das überhaupt sein, ein Kabel, was
ist das, ich erkenne es nicht, was ist das, ah, für irgendwelche Solarzellen, ok, es
gibt ja gar nix, Leute, gar nix, gut, was machen eigentlich die China-Chinesen, was
machen die China-Chinesen, 4 Euro kriegen wir jetzt, wenn wir über 5 Euro bestellen,
das heißt, ich bestelle für 6 Euro und dann kostet es nur 2 Euro, ey, jebaited, geht
nicht, guck mal, wisst ihr was ich bei AliExpress immer am besten finde, diese Seite, ohne Scheiß,
für jemand, der da noch nie drauf gewesen ist, was ist, Moment, was ist das, high IQ
USB-Stick, der denkt doch, die Seite ist Scam, die sieht nur minimal weniger Scam aus wie
Wish, wtf, das ist ja eine typische China-Chinesen-Konstruktion, Alter, ich mein, von der Idee her funktioniert
das sicherlich, ja, aber was hat das mit Android zu tun, 1 Cent kostet es, was, wie, wo steht
das, ach hier, und die Seite ist auf Russisch, da passt ja nix hier an dieser Seite, warum
da Android drauf steht, hab ich auch noch nicht so genau verstanden, das sieht irgendwie
falsch aus, dieser Anschluss, oder, das sieht irgendwie falsch aus, und ich glaube nicht,
dass das sonderlich lange hält, man sieht den, ja, man klappt den irgendwie da vorne
raus wahrscheinlich, guck, da hat die neben irgendwelche Knöpfe, ja, wahrscheinlich klappt
man den, klappt man den dann vorne aus, denn, der Mikro-USB, na geil, was, ach so, ich wollte
grad sagen, was hat das mit dem Handy zu tun, Moment, das hat auch noch einen SD-Karten-Reader,
auch noch, das ist ja richtig Multifunktion hier, USB-Karten-Leser, Mikro-USB, USB 2,
Typ C-USB, AJ45, Firewire braucht der noch, Leute, Firewire, falls das noch irgendjemand
kennt, gibt eigentlich nix mehr, was man damit anschließt, es ist einfach ein Flugzeugträger,
das kann man auch immer, richtig, richtig, high IQ Meter, USB-Stick an USB-Stick, weiß
ich ja gar kein USB-Stick, aber es ist doch ein USB-Stick, weil es hat einen Mikro-SD-Karten-Reader,
hat man je Firewire benutzt, tatsächlich, es gab einige Audio-Interfaces damals, die
Firewire verwendet haben, und das war relativ beliebt auf Macs, wie oft wollen sie dieses
Bild hier jetzt eigentlich noch rein machen, oh hier kriegt man sogar erklärt, wie es funktioniert,
ok, anhand dieses Bildes, aha, hier muss man draufdrücken und dann kommt das irgendwie
raus, sieht ganz schön fummelig aus, Attention, ok, man kann nicht SD-Karte und USB mitmachen,
ok, ja das leuchtet ein, hier hätte man vielleicht den Zeilenumbruch ein bisschen schöner machen
können, oder, war alles ok, nicht schnelle verschiffen, aber war alles wie beschrieben,
ich habe versucht es und es funktioniert gut, danke, empfehlen alles, obviously, also man
bekommt ja bei Aliexpress wirklich alle möglichen Blödsinn, dafong, dafong professional, phone
case store, ah der hat einen USB-Adapter, alles klar, oh high quality Aliexpress Werkzeugleute,
auf gehts, Autowerkzeuginnen, oh ja, das sieht schon so aus, als überlebt es nicht
mehr als eine Anwendung, das ganze Zeug hier, das sieht auf dem Bild schon alles unglaublich,
unglaublich billig aus, gut, Moment, was war denn das hier, habt ihr die Masken gesehen,
was war denn das, jetzt ist es leider weg, was waren dann diese komischen Masken hier,
jetzt sieht man es nicht mehr, ok, China-Chinesen-Zeug, genug, was auch immer, China-Chinesen-Zeug,
alles klar, gut, jetzt müssen wir auch mal bescheiden, was es bei Aliexpress so tolles
gibt, Abzocke an der Haustür, der Trick mit den wertlosen Büchern, will allen Ernstes
irgendjemand, ist es der neueste Enkeltrick oder wie, mein Opa, das sieht schon so überzogen
billig aus, dass es eigentlich nur fake sein kann, meinem Opa wollten sie auch mal damals
Lederjacken verkaufen an der Haustür, da hat sich dann auch noch scammen lassen und nicht
nur scammen lassen, die haben ihn dann glaube ich gefragt, ob sie irgendwie mal aufs Klo
dürfen oder so und da hat die aufs Klo gelassen, da haben sie ihm auch noch das Geld aus der
Schublade im Schlafzimmer geklaut und er hat nichts mitbekommen, gut vielleicht sogar besser
als dass er nichts mitbekommen hat, wer weiß, vielleicht werden die noch aggressiv geworden,
danach war die Anzeige raus, die Polizei wollte erst nichts machen, weil er sie ja freiwillig
reingelassen hat, Keckel, als ist Stehlen okay von Leuten, die man freiwillig ins Haus
lässt, es war auch geil, die haben ihm was geklaut und die Polizei meinte ernsthaft
damals zu uns, sie hatten keinen Bock was zu machen, meinte damals ernsthaft zu uns,
er hätte die ja freiwillig reingelassen, also Leute merken, wenn euch jemand freiwillig
ins Haus lässt, dürft ihr den beklauen, das ist überhaupt kein Ding, das ist ein
Ding, das ist auch Polizei approved, die hatten einfach nur keinen Bock, aber sie mussten
ja dann, bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig, wenn man da hartnäckig ist, aber sie haben
ja dann den Kram sogar gefunden wieder, nach 2-3 Wochen, ja muss man, dann haben sie eine
Message wurde geploggt von Twitch, weil dort ein nicht erlaubtes Wort drin aufgetaucht
ist, das geht nicht auf Twitch, direkt instant shadowbanned jetzt, wie läuft deine Job so,
ich hatte ein Vorstellungsgespräch am Montag, diesen Montag ruf ich da nochmal an und sag
dann ob ich will oder nicht will, die Horrorhäuser, naja gibt es in Frankfurt auch genug, guckt
euch mal die Häuser in der Niederstraße an, die sind bestimmt auch nicht weniger Horror,
das ist so ein Ding in Frankfurt Leute, wenn ihr jemals, solltet ihr jemals nach Frankfurt
fahren, es gibt da so eine Richtung wo ihr nicht rausgehen solltet, zeig euch, ja, also
hier vorne, hier vorne ist der Hauptbahnhof, so und wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof rausgeht,
äh, chat, wo ist der Button, wo ist der, ah hier, da, so, wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof rausgeht,
das ist übrigens gar nicht der Hauptbahnhof, das hier ist der Hauptbahnhof, hier, hier
ist der Hauptbahnhof, wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof rausgeht, ja, dann geht nicht den Weg hier
oben, hier oben ist ganze, ganze Assi Mist, alles hier, ganz vergessen, also geht nicht
hier rum, sondern geht hier rum, ja, Kaiserstraße, Münchner Straße, das ist zwar auch Assi hier
in der Ecke, aber nicht so Assi wie hier, weil hier an dieser Ecke, ich bin gar nicht
sicher, hier Niederstraße zu Weser, Weserstraße, Moselstraße, hier so an dieser Ecke, hier
über auch, da sind auch die ganzen, diese Drogen, äh, Dings, diese Ausgabenstellen
und irgendwelche, also hier hängt alles auf der Straße rum, da willste nicht hin, sieht
von oben nicht so schlimm aus, aber die Ecke hier ist richtig, generell, diese ganze Ecke
hier auch am Hauptbahnhof, auch wenn du, es ist im Prinzip auch hier hängen auch viele
rum, wenn du von der Seite hier rüberläufst zum, wenn du hier so rüberläufst zum Hauptbahnhof
von, von der Seite, es ist, ach generell, Frankfurt ist einfach nur eklig, wieso ist
eigentlich in jeder Stadt die Gegend um den Hauptbahnhof, die Assi die Gegend, das ist
eine gute Frage, ja, da sammelt sich irgendwie alles und hier, also wenn, übrigens noch
was, wenn ihr beim Hauptbahnhof, wenn ihr am Hauptbahnhof reingeht, dann geht vorne rein
oder nehmt diesen Seiteneingang auf der Seite, nicht hier oben, hier oben ist der McDonalds
irgendwo, hier ist der, ne hier, hier irgendwo an der Seite ist der McDonalds Eingang, sieht
man hier gar nicht, aber irgendwo hier ist der McDonalds Eingang und hier gammeln, also
hier auf der Seite so zu dem Eingang, hier gammeln auch immer die ganzen Assis rum, da
siehst du auch Leute nackig rumlaufen und sowas tagsüber und keine Leute, die man sich
gerne nackig angucken will, glaubst du mir, alles andere als Hyper Gatschi, sag ich, also
in Berlin am Hauptbahnhof fand ich auch eklig, nicht so, da ich da jetzt wahnsinnig oft gewesen
bin, das erste Mal, als ich in Berlin war, war zur Battlefield 1 Event, ich war vorher
noch nie in Berlin und das erste, was ich hatte, ich hab die Hauptbahnhof, ich hab die,
die Tür aufgemacht und was heißt die Tür, ich bin durch die Tür gelaufen, also den Ausgang
vom Berliner Hauptbahnhof und das erste, was mich war, hat mich gegen ein Penner ins Gesicht
gehustet, da hab ich mir gedacht, jawoll, wieder heim, gibt's da Street View, ja da
gibt's Street View, allerdings nur Street View von 2006 oder so, wie, 2022, WTF, die
haben wirklich Street Viewed wieder in Deutschland, MonkaS, guckt euch das mal an, Pog, ach Privatpersonen
als Street View, ok, ok, ok, ja komm, gucken wir uns mal, gucken wir uns mal die ASI Ecke
an, jedes Land hat ja mittlerweile Street View plus Deutschland nicht, wo hab ich gesagt,
hier Niederstraße, ist das hier oben die jetzt, ja genau, die Ecke, die Ecke, da ist, da
ist ASI Stellz angesagt Leute, ja, hier sieht man schon, guck, hier sind schon die ganzen
Spezialisten am Start, da wobei, ja guck mal da, da sitzen schon, da sitzen schon die
ersten in der Ecke und bereiten sich ihre nächste Wahlzeit zu, da siehst du schon hier,
da hängt einer auf der Erde, da hängt einer auf der Erde, da werden sich die neuesten
Spritzen aufgezogen, war hier lang, nein, Keck, ach hier gibt es nichts oder was, ach
hier konnte der nicht durchfahren, deswegen, weil hier hängen auch immer gerne rum, also
die Gegend Leute, ich sag euch, die ist wirklich, das ist, da wollte ich auf jeden Fall nicht,
nicht lang laufen, ja, irgendwo hier hinten hab ich auch mal live nen Überfall auf der
Straße mitgekriegt, wo einer 2 Mädels ausgeraubt hat und das blöde daran war, die kannten
den sogar, die haben dem dann nachgerufen mit seinem Namen, der Typ war halt wahrscheinlich
komplett durch im Kopf und hat Leute überfallen, die ihn kennen, nur in Frankfurt Leute, nur
in Frankfurt, ja, top, top Gegend hier, ja die ausgeraubten kennen den, die könnten zur
Polizei gehen und sagen, na Karl hat mich überfallen, haben sie aber anscheinend nicht
oder weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, ich hab den vorhin mitgekriegt, ich hab nur mitgekriegt,
dass einer von hinten an gerannt gekommen ist, hat der eine auf den Kopf gehauen, hat
die Tasche mit, also hat die Tasche entrissen und ist weg gerannt und die haben hinterher
geschrien, Karl was machst du denn, Frankfurt only, Frankfurt Gütesstraße Louis Vuitton
Storz, zahl die Kollektion barfick auf Sponsor, oh man, so was können wir uns dann angucken,
useless, don't buy a wifi range extender, ja useless, useless sind sie nicht zwangsläufig,
kann die schon dafür verwenden, ja, ist halt, vor allem wenn man Bandbreite haben will nicht
unbedingt so das Beste, kannst du einen Cloud Storage empfehlen, Offsidesicherung, achso
ne, ne, kenn ich mich aktuell nicht aus, ich hab die hier ne Weile verwendet mal, ich weiß
gar nicht ob die noch normales Zeug haben und wie die Preise sind, mittlerweile, unlimited
data, die Hetzner Storage Box tatsächlich, ja stimmt die gibt es ja auch noch, Hetzner,
Cloud, Prices, da müsste ich eigentlich mal wieder Sellout machen, Prices, Storage, ist
das die Storage Box, oh, das ist ganz schön teuer, ey AWS ist sicherlich deutlich teurer,
Storage Boxes, hier 20TB 48€, das ist preislich durchaus in Ordnung, also 1TB für 3,81€
kann man sich durchaus gönnen oder 5 für 12€, also 3€ finde ich tatsächlich ganz
gut, 1TB Offside reicht den meisten Leuten, ja, wenn man halt auch wirklich mal guckt,
was ist wichtig, was muss ich wirklich Offside sichern, weil ich meine, irgendwelche, ok
es sind Fotografen oder so, die kommen damit nicht hin, aber die ganzen Sachen, die wirklich
viel Speicher brauchen, von VM-Images bis sonst was, die muss man ja nicht wirklich
Offside sichern, also ich finde gerade das erste ist gar nicht mal so übel, tja, so
was können wir uns angucken Leute, zeige ich dir, Leute ich habe ein Problem, ich muss
noch mal aufs Klo vorher, es ging noch nicht bevor ich den Stream angemacht habe, aber
jetzt drückt es, ich bin mal kurz, ich bin mal kurz, Aftk, Aftk, Pepo, Pupu, ich bin
mal kurz.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Das war's für heute.
anscheinend also kann es ja nicht hingehen
Ne habe ich nicht
Der hättest du mal gigabit jetzt
Ja, also was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an das fps ist dead
Lässt eine hier auf der launch
Ich kann mir nicht voll vorstellen dass er über modern warfare redet das wäre relativ sinnlos und jeder weiß dass es jetzt dead ist
Installing mac os on a microsoft laptop
22 minuten mensch
Was kürzer knackigeres floppy's disc suppliers
Moment wollen die uns ernsthaft erzählen leute kaufen heute mal business is booming
also
Das das das kann ich das kann ich nur nur beschränkt glauben sekunde
Ja, wie wäre es wenn die einfach nicht musik drüber gemacht hätten wenn er redet
Also nur so
Ja, gut, das hat auch nichts damit zu tun was es müsste es jetzt booming wäre
An wen verkaufte die denn
In was was ist das
Emproidery business das wort habe ich noch nie gehört
Stickerei ach du meinst dass man damit die diese irgendwelche maschinen mit programmieren kann oder
Aber der hat der hat hier die die die highly advanced floppy disk quickdraw skills
Wo die
eigentlich wirklich die meisten flugzeuge heute verwenden echt noch disketten die
wurden noch nicht abgekradet auf irgendwas
500 disketten am tag
gut die krasse menge ist es jetzt auch nett ein floppy auf usb adapter ja so was das
wäre mal high IQ auf der einen seite quasi so eine fake floppy disk und auf der anderen
seite einen usb stick das gibt es bestimmt moment moment floppy disk usb adapter
ja moment es gibt
ich meinte jetzt eigentlich eher das umgedrehte dass man quasi so eine fake diskette hat wo man
ein usb stick dran anschließt sowas da ja
500 ganz ehrlich 500 disketten am tag ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass das booming ist
früher hat sie hast du das kettenpack gekauft das waren zehn stück drinne also also wie das da
waren aber gut ich war für die heutige zeit ist natürlich trotzdem viel das würde man nicht
denken dass einhändler 500 disketten verkauft aber insgesamt ist nicht viel ich habe mir damals auch
immer so die cd spindeln gekauft da waren 50 oder 100 glaube ich sogar cds drinne so eine cd rw
spindel so ein ding guck hier nicht 10er pack keckel hier sowas hat man sich da gekauft wenn
schon ja sowas sowas sowas hat man sich damals gekauft hier 50er pack cd rohlinge oder wurde
gebrannt das ist ja auch total out habt ihr überhaupt noch ein cd brenner oder dvd brenner
oder irgendwie ein optisches laufwerk also frauen wir mal zwei zwei sachen erstens habt ihr noch
ein optisches laufwerk im rechner und zweitens habt ihr einen cd brenner bzw dvd brenner im
rechner extern ja gut zählt auch also einfach nur angeschlossen tatsächlich also ich glaube
ich hatte die letzten wahrscheinlich schon zehn jahre oder so nein vielleicht nicht ganz zehn
vielleicht doch zehn also die letzten zwei rechner hatten beide kein optisches laufwerk mehr
oh jetzt wird es aber advanced hier guck mal da ein externes disketten laufwerk und ein brenner
mit light scribe ja das gab es damals ja auch dass man dort auf die cds oben dann so ein bisschen
beschriftung gravieren konnte ein blu ray brenner ein modrive kennt kennt ihr noch dings hier kennt
jemand noch diese dinger zwar damals der shit man war unglaublich beeindruckt dass man 100
megabyte oder war es nur 80 oder war es 120 ich bin mir gar nicht mehr so ganz sicher ich
habe jetzt ich habe im hintergrund ist ich habe mir noch von 100 100 dass man 100 mb auf eine
diskette bekommen hat die dinger waren halt langsam erst fack ja das hatte da das hat
da nie jemand benutzt
click of death das ist der vorging vom red ring of death bei der xbox oder wie wie schnell
waren denn die dinger die waren ich kann mich dran die waren unglaublich langsam
die waren nicht blazingly fast hier guck mal 1,4 mb die sekunde ich mein gut 100 mb du
hast all eineinhalb minuten ungefähr kopiert 100 mb das war in der damaligen zeit durchaus in
ordnung ich meine normale floppy disk hatte das halt gesamtkapazität was es in einer in
der sekunde macht angeschlossen wurden die dinger glaube ich hauptsächlich tatsächlich
über scsi oder scar sie wie das die leute nennen teilweise ich ich persönlich bin ja
für scsi nicht für scar sie oder manche sagen auch skizzi skizzi oder sowas ähnliches ok
es gab sogar usb varianten das ist mir neu das wusste ich feier war ja oder ultra bei
was zum teufel ist ultra bei ach irgendwas von ibm per ide kabel die meisten leute werden
es über ide kabels angeschlossen haben und falls ich noch irgendjemand dran erinnern
kann ide masters das darf man heute wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so nennen master slave cable
select da gab es noch jumper an den geräten man musste gucken dass man nicht etwa aus
versehen das cd laufwerk als master macht und die festplatte als slave und solche sachen
das war noch nicht ganz so idiotensicher wie heute wobei es eigentlich auch schon relativ
simpel gewesen ist aber trotzdem da konnte man auch mehr verkacken jumper hinten an der
festplatte und am cd laufwerk ich glaube aktuelle laufwerke haben gar kein jumper mehr oder
haben aktuelle sata ssd und also ssd ist auf keinen fall aber haben haben noch festplatten
jumper nie oder ich habe mich schon eine weite keine festplatte mehr von hinten angeguckt
ehrlich gesagt top management wir haben noch ein bisschen mehr ja das waren auch zeiten
hier und wer es noch nicht gesehen hat das waren solche solche dinger ja die da übrigens
ähnliche ähnliche dinger hatte man damals auch für drucker drucker anschlüsse verwendet
so also optisch sahen die ähnlich aus
ide damals hat man grafikkarten auch nicht per pc express angeschlossen agp slot das
war quasi der pc express vorgänger
so genug boomer zeug was können wir uns dann angucken zeige ich mal her
this fps ist dead dead gel
less than a year after launch ja gut fünf minuten fünf minuten können wir uns angucken
ich also wenn das wirklich modern warfare 2019 ist da muss ich aber kacken kann es
aber nicht sein dass es darum geht
game awards juckt das überhaupt irgendjemand noch
kann ich mich nicht drinnen
ich kann mich litig absolut nicht daran erinnern was es für ein game sein soll
nein tu fife
sagt mir absolut
sagt mir null keine ahnung was das ist
nein tu fife gut das in armee arbeitszeiten aber
habe ich doch nie was von gehört
habe ich legit noch nie was von gehört
auch noch nichts von gehört
ja muss man sich ja auch nicht wundern wenn man nur alpha betas early access und unfertiges
game hat ich mein ganz ehrlich warum
kennt ihr das ihr geht auf steam steam schlägt euch irgendwas vor ihr denkt euch hey das
könnt ja was für euch sein ihr macht die seite in steam auf und das erste was ihr
seht dass dieses game im early access ist und dann mache ich gleich people leave damit
die seite gleich zugemacht ich spiele aus prinzip keine early access games und mir wäre
es am liebsten ich könnte bei steam komplett early access rausfiltern das geht leider nicht
gut bettel viel 2042 ist ein early access wenn überhaupt als fertig verkauft mich würde
mal eine statistik interessieren wie viel also prozentual gesehen ja
wie viel der games die in early access gehen werden fertig gestellt was würdet ihr schätzen
chat also ich würde sagen 20 prozent wenn es hoch kommt wenn es hoch kommt 20 prozent
werden jemals fertig oder was meint ihr wieviel sind also ich sag 20 prozent aber wie gesagt
da wäre ich das ist wahrscheinlich schon viel zu viel 50 50 es gibt so viele games die
rauskommen und verschimmeln im early access ja ich kann es mir vorstellen also ich also
ich würde am liebsten early access komplett rausfiltern auf steam es gibt so viele sachen
wo ich bin cool und dann sehe ich early access dann mache ich gleich zu 21 und dann ein release
out of early access was fertiggestellt ist ja gut das ist definitionsfrage ganz einfach
ich würde ganz nahe liegen machen sobald es halt eben aus early access rauskommt sobald
es kein early access tag mehr hat sobald es laut dem hersteller quasi fertig aber fertig
heißt ja nicht dass es keinen support mehr gibt aber reif zum release ist ja sobald es
kein early access tag mehr hat also wie viel wie viel prozent der spiele vom early access
wirklich zu können ja auch der hersteller selbst definieren fertig sind aber 20 prozent
hochkommt würde mich echt mal interessieren ob es eine statistik gibt da ist richtig viel
müll dabei das ist halt das problem
ich glaube das einzige early access spiel was ich jemals länger gespielt habe war factorio
ist aber auch richtig nice gewesen da schon und man hat auch gesehen der arbeite da gefühlt
irgendwie täglich dran und das release war dann auch glaube ich nur noch irgendwie angekündigt
irgendwie nur irgendwie in zwei monaten oder so ja factorio ist also ohne scheiß oder factorio
ist als eines der high IQ spiele die es gibt ihr müsst mal gucken was da leute mittlerweile
mit bauen das ist echt nicht mehr normal
das wahrscheinlich ist eigentlich ein problem gewesen
ihr wisst doch wie das ist wenn es um potenzial geht kannst du das fast jedem game nachsagen
ich mein battlefield 2042 es hat auch potenzial gerade mit portal gehabt aber die frage ist
ja auch ob man dieses potenzial irgendwie nutzt und das ja potenzial alleine reicht
halt nicht ist das world war 3 nein das ist 9 to 5 habe ich auch in der nächsten folge
gehört
war immerhin da haben bestimmt hat alle die premium sachen gekauft haben übelst rein
gehätet
containermaps haben die haben die ex haben die ex da ist developer
aber ich muss sagen ehrlich gesagt sieht eigentlich ganz spaßig aus aber sieht ganz spaßig aus
hat anscheinend gereicht das waffenhändchen sieht ein bisschen unrund aus aber gut kann
man jetzt nicht sagen also ich mach das ganz anders bei mir ist komplett anders solange
da early access dran steht guck ich es erst gar nicht an gerade wenn man es kaufen soll
im early access
also der grund warum ich world war 3 mir nicht mehr angeguckt habe ist mail ru anti cheat
ich mein anti cheats sind ja mittlerweile schon schlimm genug aber wenn man wirklich noch
den russischen anti cheat auf dem rechner haben
der hat kein mail ru anti cheat mehr ja der hat jetzt den nachfolger vom mail ru anti cheat
drinne
was ready or not hatte zwischenzeitlich multiplayer ich dachte das ist so single player super
realistisch kampagnen ding ne nicht kampagnen ding co-op ding
ich weiß nicht
also ich weiß nicht ob man ich meine es werden es werden doch schon genug games hergestellt
komplett lieblose dinger weil man denkt das ist das was die leute haben wollen und nicht
weil man denkt das ist das game was man selbst gerne spielen will das finde ich verkehrt
also gerade älteren games merkst du doch an dass das spiele sind die so sind wie sie
sind weil die leute die das entwickelt haben quasi die spiele so gebaut haben dass sie
sich gedacht haben das ist was dass ich so selbst gerne spielen will oder das ist was
mir so auch gefallen würde und nicht so ja welches genre läuft denn gerade gut ja bettel
royal ja lass mal ein bettel royal machen ja lass mal vor ein paar jahren in moba machen
oder lass mal den game mit zombies und lass mal den game mit survival und so machen das
ist doch übelster rotz alter die sollen games machen die sie selbst geil finden und das
merkt man klar das mag dann vielleicht nicht zwangsläufig das genre sein was das nächste
fortnite wird aber muss ja auch mal sagen fortnite ist nicht als fortnite geboren worden
mit dem mit mit dem gedanken so nach dem motto wir machen jetzt ein bettel royal was die
ganze zwölfjährigen der welt feiern fortnite auch nicht fortnite war ursprünglich mal
irgend so komisches koop horde modus game also ich weiß nicht komplett im trend hinterher
rennen das mag vielleicht schon erfolgreich sein wenn du wirklich millionen und milliarden
naht und massig developer resourcen und alles mögliche aber ich glaube gerade wenn du jetzt
ein normales studio bist oder noch oder gerade auch ein hersteller einzelne entwickler vielleicht
mit zwei drei andere leuten warum solltest du auf irgendwie den riesen zug aufspringen
nur weil das gerade angesagt ist dann ist doch besser du machst ein gutes game was dir selbst
gefällt und schaffst damit andere davon zu begeistern auch wenn es halt keine millionen
sind kann ich jeder das nächste flappi berth ich war ganz im ernst es kann doch eh keiner
wirklich ab abschätzen so richtig welche games jetzt trenden und was nicht seriously
meint ihr der typ der flappi berth programmiert hat hat gedacht alter ich mache jetzt den
das neueste geile game was millionen spielen werden ne der hat irgendein programmiert tutorial
oder sowas wahrscheinlich gemacht ich mein flappi berth ist ja so ziemlich das simpelste
an games was du machen konntest aus irgendwelchen gründen hat das so viral voll eingeschlagen
man muss sich nur mal hand anschauen das spielen die der selbst ja es ist immer ein gutes zeichen
dafür wenn die entwickler selbst ihre games spielen und daraufhin halt auch vielleicht
sachen anpassen im game das ist halt eine sache die ich mir nicht vorstellen kann dass bei
da ist das großartig passiert also sie haben ihre games schon gespielt man hat ja ein bisschen
also manche leute haben das game gespielt man hat aber das gameplay gesehen leute könnt
ihr euch noch auf auf dem reveal stream an das gameplay erinnern oh warte mal oder war
das bei dem nee sorry leute nicht im reveal stream das war in dem event wo ich eingeladen
hab ich ganz vergessen in dem event das wurde gar nicht gestreamt in dem event hat man gameplay
gesehen von von von einem dice entwickler und leute kein wunder das battlefield so geworden
ist wie es geworden ist alter wie die das game gespielt haben ist absoluter wahnsinn
der kell ist nur nur mit c4 über die map geflogen der ist muss muss ihr euch vorstellen
der kell ist auf orbital auf dem auf auf die auf die die antennen und und hochhäuser hoch
gelaufen für zwei minuten hat nichts anderes gemacht hoch gelaufen und ist dann von dort
runter gesprungen und mit dem fallschirm geflogen hat c4 von oben auf die leute geschmissen
und das war das ganze also das hat er die ganze zeit gemacht jetzt ganze match über
aber die hätten wirklich ihr game mal mehr spielen sollen ich meine ich sage ich habe
es jetzt schon öfters als beispiel gebracht ja es gibt ja ein paar konferenz talks von
von id software früher von von den doom entwicklern und den quake entwicklern die gesagt haben
sie haben den kram nicht nur selbst gespielt sie wollten das game machen was sie selbst
spielen wollen und vor allem bei ihnen gab es kein burn out oder sowas das war quasi
ihr leben so das spiel zu die games zu entwickeln und zu spielen das war sogar so schlimm dass
das einer gesagt hat wenn er aufs klo geht geht es ihm quasi schlecht weil er nicht weiter
programmieren kann und und dann hat er sich irgendwelche ständer auf dem klo gebaut dass
er auf dem klo irgendwie seinen seinen pc hinstellen konnte und dann oder sein laptop
weiß ich auch schon laptop waren dass er dann auf dem klo weiter programmieren konnte also
sprich der hat der hat gemeint ihm ging es quasi schlecht wenn er mal aufs klo musste
weil er konnte nicht weiterentwickeln das war auch noch andere zeit okay aber ich weiß
immerhin die finden ihr game selbst halt geil ist doch ist doch dass das was vielen games
heute auch noch fehlt ja den hätte ilon mask gemocht wahrscheinlich wirst du mal was on
2 stream dazu müsste ich war son 2 erst mal eine weile spielen wie gesagt ich habe immer
nur eine runde bisher erst gespielt so eine richtige runde so solo ins in quartz und ein
paar leute gekillt cool hat gewonnen und dann wurde ich halt überrannt aber wo wir gerade
dabei sind kommen wir heulen uns jetzt den rent an der sonderlord der german sonderlord
der erklärt uns jetzt warum war son 2 eine zumutung ist das wollte ich gestern schon
gucken der rented immer so schön auch über battlefield und am lustigsten finde ich immer
wenn ich mir ihn dann angucke wenn er heli fliegt ja und sich darüber aufregt dass es
irgendjemand wagt auf den heli zu schießen das war immer geil so nach dem motto alles
kacknubs ja krasse heliskill was da schießt einer auf mein heli alle mit dem nupp raketenwerfer
auch noch scheiß entwickler warum ist der nupp raketenwerfer und die nupp rakete und
die nupp granate naja aber ich guck ja trotzdem mal gerne an so es ist immer noch übertrieben
battlefield 2242 so hallo hallo hallo es ist mir an dieser stelle schon mal ein persönliches
anliegen der redet immer so wahnsinnig motiviert irgendwie auch euch eine vorabwarnung zu geben
dass das ja eines der negativsten videos auf diesem kanal werden wir auf gehts was
heißen es wird außerdem das einzige video sein was ich noch zu mw2 hier auf dem kanal
haben werde weil es so traurig und so frech ist was sie abgeliefert haben dass ich mir
das nicht weiter antun möchte das ist genau für eine sache gut nämlich jetzt hier ein
video zu machen damit das ist das ist für eine sache gut ich dachte ich dachte jetzt
erzählt er wieder was über nupps und casual spieler da erzählt er auch immer gerne was
drüber bis 100 euro durch das video mitzunehmen mich dann zu freuen hat er nicht unrecht dass
ich sozusagen schmerzensgeld dafür bekomme mir diese qual angetan hat er nicht unrecht
vielleicht sollte ich auch ein video zu warzone 2 machen gibt auf jeden fall gut views und
kohle aktuell und ich gebe euch brief und siehe dafür würde das hier nicht unter dem
titel call of duty stehen es hätte innerhalb von einer woche keine spieler mehr weil es
auch keine spieler verdient und jeder der das hier noch weiter spiel ist offensichtlich
jetzt geht es zur sache kann man sich ausdrücken es tut mir leid leute es ist aber wirklich
so und ich sage dass obwohl ich warzone 1 gut fand das kam raus es hat spaß gemacht
es hat funktioniert vor allem hat es funktioniert und die frage ist wird das genauso letztes
warzone video bei ihm wie meinen letzten battlefield 2042 videos jaja ist eine gute frage nächstes
nächsten dienstag kommt die neue season da werde ich auch noch was zu machen guckt euch
diese scheiße an hier funktioniert überhaupt nichts es ist einfach eine einzige show dieses
game auf einer stufe als kaputt zu bezeichnen mit anderen kaputten spiel die fallout 76
oder bettel 4 2042 es scheint ein wenig diese anderen games die weiß gott auch scheint
ein wenig kaputt zu sein oder immer noch eine fucking beleidigung ich habe schon wenig
erwartet aber ich wurde immer noch enttäuscht ich habe wenigstens erwartet ich habe das
video schon zweimal leiser gemacht er wurde immer lauter über die ganze minute das ist
funktioniert aber selbst das ist nicht der fall wenn man überhaupt spielen kann ihr
seht das ja hier gerade ich will starten es geht nicht es geht nicht ja gut das problem
hatte ich auch muss ich aber ehrlich sagen das war halt auch am release tag und dass
es am release tag probleme gibt mit mit surfer und matchmaking da habe ich da habe ich schon
fast mit gerechnet es erzählt mir ich soll das game kaufen ich rufe die fl auf es erzählt
mir das verdammte spiel solche dinge passieren ja das menu und die das squad management ist
eh komplette zumutung am laufenden band die ganze fucking zeit sogar bei leuten die das
fucking game gekauft haben ich muss mich zusammenreißen ich schreie schon wieder rum obwohl ich nicht
mal geld in das game gesteckt habe regt es mich trotzdem so auf weil es eine frechheit
ist weil es so schlecht ist und weil ich mich frage wie sowas passieren kann und wenn man
dann spielen kann dann wird man ja endlich in dieser tollen wüsten map mit rpg ak und
bombendrohne den inneren terroristen embraceen da kommt auch freude auf in der perfekt passenden
gegend dazu ich weiß gar nicht was ihr habt das ist doch eine super map und dann drücke
ich hier ein paar mal auf den zündenknopf und dann wirft mein charakter erstmal scheiß
semtex erst mal semtex gewaistet kommt freude auf aber jetzt mal spaß beiseite diese map
hier hat auch so ihre probleme offensichtlich wisst ihr was zum beispiel richtig geil ist
es gibt jetzt so neue black sites dafür braucht man ein bisschen leid zu kommen und dann nimmt
man hier ein auftrag an wo man irgendwelche träsoren aufspringen muss und dann ist er
in der black site drin wo man nicht rein kann man ja gut das das stimmt schon das spiel
hat also generell muss man das muss man auch wirklich mal sagen also modern warfare 2 hat
an vielen stellen echt so ein feintuning problem einfach also das ist jetzt nicht dass es einfach
komplett progen ist wie am anfang battlefield 2042 ist es ist es in vielen fällen auch
aber es ist einfach so so un über nenne ich unüberlegt so so so es fehlt immer was ich
meine es so wie sie wissen hat jemand quasi schon das richtig programmiert es funktioniert
aber es fühlt sich nicht so an ja beispielsweise wenn du rein lädst in die map kommt der lade
bildschirm zweimal das menü freest immer zwischendurch wenn leute in dein squad rein
join dann dann ruckel das erst mal ganz das ist so ja prinzipiell ist das da aber eigentlich
müsste es jetzt nochmal hübsch gemacht werden und das hat man nicht gemacht also fühlt
sich das an
dass man den unterschied zwischen spieler und bot nicht genau
checkt ist tatsächlich bescheuert
und weil das alles irgendwie scheiße aussieht mit diesen ganzen diversen bullshit skins
die es in diesem game gibt kann man die von außen teilweise nicht mal gut erkennen und
wofür ist alles dass man einen haufen loot bekommt der sich teilweise ineinander back
sodass man ihn nicht mehr aufsammeln kann gratulation und möglicherweise ein black
side schlüssel womit man zu einer black side eiern kann wenn man da hoffentlich lebendig
ankommt ja da kann man das ist also das ist also das ist eines der neuen möglichkeiten
wie man waffen und loadouts bekommen kann diese pvm-missionen ob es das wirklich gebraucht
hätte ich bin mir doch unschlüssig ja
und dann kommt dann fucking juggernaut npc boss der tank und tank und tank so viele headshots
c4 packchen auch noch ertankt und tankt und tankt es ist ihm egal wisst ihr wie in fallout
76 bei nuke der winter die haben verstanden wenn man pve gegner auch pve boss gegner in
seinem battle royal hat dann müssen die trotzdem verdammt schnell sterben weil die ablenkung
die man durch die hat allein schon ausreichend ist dass es einen umbringt weil dann spieler
ankommen die das schießen hören und sich denken ja man hat abgelenkte leute da das
ist so ja ja genau so passiert das unter garantie auch ständig hier so ist es uns zumindest
passiert bei dem einmal wo ich das dann hier gemacht habe für videos weg komisch oder
dass die vollversager bei bug tester die von pvp überhaupt keine ahnung haben und mit
fallout 76 ein historisch schlechtes game abgeliefert haben da noch bessere design entscheidungen
treffen als die bei cod mit jahren der erfahrung in sachen pvp die denken sich dann jetzt
will das wessner oh let's go bullet sponge ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen kann man
so geistig ich darf es ja nicht sagen sonst wird das video wieder gestreikt zur belohnung
für den ganzen spaß kriegt man eben noch mehr looter ein umfeldscan um den ganzen
laden drum herum der einem wenig bringt weil man da weg muss eine verbesserte drohne die
die blickrichtung der gegner anzeigt was durchaus nice ist und eine minigun die einem nur am
nahkampf was bringt weil sie auf range ziemlich schlecht ist super toll oder seht ihr das
hier das ist der gulag haben sie jetzt auch verkackt das sind jetzt ja das muss ich sagen
finde ich auch keine gute idee ich verstehe nicht den sinn dahinter warum es zwei basses
zwei ist vielleicht weil man das denn weil man dort jetzt die sachen im zwei basses zwei
modus recyceln kann keine ahnung warum es zwei basses zwei ist finde ich leuchtet mir
auch absolut nicht ein zumal es ja dann auch noch einen boss gegner gibt den ehrlich gesagt
nie jemand macht zwei mit randoms zusammen manchmal auch mit teammates zusammen wenn
es vom timing her passt aber nicht immer teilweise ist auch so dass die teammates zur gleichen
zeit gestorben sind aber in ein anderes gulag gekommen sind ist doch toll oder ist doch
geil und auch hier rennt dann ein npc mit der minigun rum der einem auf den sack geht
warum warum macht man sowas was das verstehe ich auch nicht genau warum das zwei basses
zwei sein muss wie glaube ich schon erwähnt die späteren gebeten hat bei den ganzen sachen
da nie jemand tromm von warzone 1 habe ich nicht gespielt vielleicht haben leute darum
gebeten ich glaube aber nicht dass leute darum gebeten haben es werden nicht sachen gemacht
unbedingt weil die spieler das haben wollen weil sowas eine dumme idee ist warum macht
man das dann apropos man kann jetzt auch im gulag looten beispielsweise eine dreierweste
und die behält man dann das ist wegen mal eine ganz coole idee dass man da nicht komplett
nackt rauskommt quasi und die andere gute sache um wenigstens diesen scheiß mal in
einer hinsicht zu loben ist der zug den es auf dieser map gibt der dann auch loot drauf
hat und durch die jäger fährt und wo man auch auf den zug verhalten kann das fand
ich ganz cool das hat spaß gemacht aber das ist auch irgendwie die einzige sache die ich
dieser map und bei extension diesem ganzen modus abgewinnen kann ansonsten ist es wirklich
von vorne bis hinten eine einzige shit show und ich habe da noch so viel mehr clips um
das zu demonstrieren hier beispielsweise ich möchte mich anschließen geht nicht ist toll
oder funktioniert einfach nicht das ist kaputt ja das party system ist tatsächlich komplett
kaputt wir hatten auch ein riesen also ich habe es bei bei bettelnett kollege von mir
hat es bei steam und wir wollten zusammen spielen leute wisst ihr wie lange es gedauert
hat bis ich meine activischen id gefunden habe beziehungsweise er seine activischen
id dass wir miteinander spielen konnte das überhaupt erst mal freundesanfragen schicken
konnten wir haben bestimmt jeder fünf minuten geguckt wo dieser kack steht man findet es
dann irgendwie über profil und und party und eigenes profil und dann steht das irgendwo
und danach ging das in weit nicht wir haben uns gegenseitig in weiter keine chance hat
nicht funktioniert bei ihm ist er in weit erst gar nicht angekommen ich konnte bei ihm nicht
joinen über in weit wisst ihr was dann funktioniert hat wisst ihr wie es dann ging ich musste
bei mir im im profil einstellen dass ich online bin normalerweise bin ich ja immer immer als
offline angezeigt und dann musste er mir rein joinen in die party die ich euch die ich geöffnet
habe das hat dann funktioniert der in weit hat nicht funktioniert also das ist wirklich
komplett im arsch der kram es klappt nicht manchmal klappt manchmal klappt nicht das
ist next gen ich habe hier übrigens den clip gekattet der ladescreen ging ungefähr fünf
minuten dann wurde ich so begrüßt habt ihr das gerade gesehen habt ihr es gesehen hier
noch mal in zeitlupe und ran gesucht das ist ja fast wie bentfield 2042 da hast du ja auch
die ganzen low level of detail models gehabt am anfang da ist alles normal guckt man ein
bisschen weiter weg da hinten auf den tower das ist ja fast wie im ersten war zone im
ersten war zone wie erinnert sich noch an den flughafen flughafen hast du von der ase
draufgezoomt oder wurde erst mal das gebäude reingeladen pixelmatch wie soll man da zum
beispiel jetzt werden raus snipen und so was das passiert nicht einmal das passiert auch
ständig habt ihr es hier wieder gesehen auch da hat das gesicht nicht richtig geladen immer
wieder auch gesichter irgendwelche grafikfehler auch auf der map dass teilweise die linge
hier total überlappen es geht mir alles auf den sack es kommt mir ein absolutes visuelles
downgrade es fühlt sich und es spielt sich und es sieht scheiße aus dahinten tolle grafik
box oder ich finde es so toll es macht so freude es macht mir so spaß leute geben konstant ja da
haben irgendwelche leute irgendwelche entwickler verkackt die fragt mich nicht wie das heißt
irgendwelche reflection probes oder sonst was in der richtung verkackt 42 shit dafür dass
es so kaputt ist oder spielt man das hier und es ist noch viel kaputt es ist so kaputt guckt euch
die frame drops anders kann ich deren ernst sein ein viertel der lobby sieht so aus und
wahrscheinlich wegen sbm oder weil die server einfach scheiße sind aber ich vermute es liegt
an skillbase matchmaking du suchst eine lobby ja du hast fünf bis zehn minuten matchmaking
zeit und dann kriegst du eine high ping lobby mit einem ping von über 50 spiele ich bettel
vier ich habe ein ping von neun millisekunden oder bis zu elf millisekunden ja es liegt nicht
an meinem internet es liegt am dreck skillbase matchmaking und das per design weil das
irgendwer so haben will sie verdienen es alle ihren job zu verlieren am besten gleich ihr
leben noch dazu übertreibt man nicht jetzt übertreibt halt mal nicht extrem man frage mich was für
missgeburt jetzt ist aber gut ich bin festgebackt ab dem moment wo ich in die drohne reingegangen
bin ich kann mich nicht mehr bewegen ich kann überhaupt gar nichts mehr machen das sind game
breaking glitches und bugs in diesem spiel und sie gehören gefixt also also das hatte ich auch
dass das hatte ich auch dass ich am anfang ihr kennt ja diese pregame lobby wo man dann wo man
dann bis alle bis alles geladen ist und ich bin einfach mal in der pregame lobby nicht dort
geblieben wo man wo man spawn sondern bin also die leute werden ja immer ein bisschen verteilt
gesporn auf der map und können sich dann irgendwie 30 sekunden 40 sekunden lang killen bevor das
game losgeht ich bin einfach mal nur geradeaus gerannt so in dieser pregame lobby einfach nur
geradeaus und irgendwann bin ich in einer unsichtbaren wand gestackt konnte ich nicht
mal weiterlaufen aber immerhin ich bin an dem flugzeug gesporn und die runde ging normal los
das ganze game gelöscht und vermarkt genommen es ist so unglaublich schlecht natürlich bin ich
daran gestorben ich meine was soll ich sonst machen guckt euch die animatoren das video ist glaube ich nicht gelb das
liegt daran weil das hier hinten die zone ist es ist so komplett verbackt und im arsch dieses
game verdient es so sehr zu sterben und wenn ich daran denke dass leute ja gut rein wird das wird
das wird das nicht ganz ehrlich ja also ich kann das insofern schon nachvollziehen das game ist
ziemlich unüberlegt und kaputt an vielen stellen aber das ist tatsächlich wieder das gleiche wie
bei modern warfare 2019 da war der multiplayer fand ich auch schon ziemlich ja kacke und der
rest auch nicht sonderlich toll und worson hat es gerettet ich gehe davon aus es ist wieder es
wird wieder so sein worson wird das retten der multiplayer ist von arsch den multiplayer kannst
du eigentlich nur verwenden ein bisschen deine sachen zu anlocken und der rest wird wahrscheinlich
wieder einschlagen ja und das ich meine es wurde ja ein paar sachen tatsächlich ver kompliziert
nenne ich jetzt mal es gibt jetzt ja zum ersten mal ein richtiges richtiges kann man es richtiges
nennen aber es gibt ja zum ersten mal ein inventarsystem das gab es ja im ersten worson nicht
du hast jetzt ja ein inventar du kannst jetzt quasi zu den gegnerischen rucksäcken gehen dort
reinschauen und dann das rausnehmen was du willst so geld looten granaten looten und sowas also
das gab es ja vorher nicht vorher hat es halt das problem dass immer die falschen sachen vom
boden aufgehoben hast also es war es ist eigentlich dass es tatsächlich finde ich ganz gut ganz gut
geworden aber es wird nach wie vor so sein leute worson ist so so ein gewisses phenomenon so
beginn es läuft schon irgendwie fast von selbst ja es gibt zigtausend content creator die die
worson machen es gibt ganz viele leute die worson spielen und letztendlich ist worson 1 schon so
erfolgreich gewesen weil es halt eben der casual lixte aber immer noch ganz ganz gut gemachte
bettel royale shooter ist vor allem mit einer großen marke dahinter mit massig geld dahinter
viel updates dahinter und das wird bei worson 2 wieder aus genauso sein
in diesem game skins kaufen und damit dieses game am leben erhalten und dafür sorgen dass
das business hier sieht man hier sieht man das inventar dann verdient die am besten gleich mit
ich kriege so das kotzen je mehr ich darüber nachdenke desto mehr kriege ich das kotzen es
macht mich so aggressiv wisst ihr ich habe ein video also hätte er das nicht gesagt man hätte
es auch gehört gemacht wo ich mich darüber beschwert habe dass die call of duty community
battlefield kaputt macht das stimmt so nicht ganz die macht das ganze gaming kaputt die leute
dieses game unterstützen und aktiv spielen werden sie machen gaming als ganzes kaputt in
dem so eine scheiße durchgeht ja auch dieser server diese lobby hier ist wieder im arsch wie
ständig die lobbies im arsch sind ein aus fünf wenn ich ein aus vier matches stürzt ab diese
dreckskartoffelserver und warum weil die leute die dieses game machen sparen wo es nur geht sie
verdienen ich glaube mal ich weiß nicht ob es wirklich am sparen liegt sicherlich sicherlich
auch ja die wenn ich mir ausgeben aber ich glaube ganz im ernst ich glaube die sind einfach erstens
an vielen stellen ziemlich unfähig mittlerweile und das nächste ist es muss schnell gehen man
hat keine zeit weil letztendlich geht es da um massig kohle und sie haben gelernt und da
muss ich ihm in sofern schon ein bisschen recht geben weil sie haben gelernt die leute fressen
und spielen auch den unfertigen kaputtenen kram und wenn du das weißt gibt sie dir auch keine
mühe mehr warum solltest du dir auch mühe geben wenn du jetzt die ausfall hast ich baue eine sache
ein und danach hast du die warte also du baust was ein danach hast du die wahl ich entwickle an was
neuem oder aber ich polle ich jetzt das weiß ich vorher eingebaut habe ja warum sollte man das
polishen wenn sie leute auch so fressen da ist schon was dran zumal man mit dem anderen dann
wieder geld verdienen kann die geben sich die geben sich halt einfach keine mühe mehr als
die leute fressen da ist schon was dran diesem spiel und sie müssen trotzdem noch sparen die
beide eskalieren halt komplett hier sparen alles was man einsparen kann wird eingespart und wenn es die
gottverdammten server sind die wichtig sind damit das spiel vernünftig läuft scheiß drauf einsparen
damals im original mw2 hat man sich auch die mühe gemacht und die scheiß licenzen gekauft damit
die waffen richtig heißen war das hießen die wirklich die hießen doch auch schon in mw1 nicht
richtig oder in mw1 2019 im original mw1 hießen die richtig 2009 oder so
mw2 im original mw2 ja da hießen die richtig das ist auch so ein ding wisst ihr ich hab da ich hab
da zwei ich hab da zwei zwei vermutungen warum das so ist mit mit den waffen bezeichnung das erste
ist also das erste ist das was er auch sagt das könnte sein dass man sich das geld sparen will
aber das glaube ich gar nicht mal wisst ihr was ich eher glaube ich glaube die wollen nicht mit
der waffen lobby in verbindung gebracht werden so nach dem motto also die wollen den shitstorm
vermeiden dass irgendjemand sagt sie hätten die waffen lobby supported mit mit mit geld vielleicht
ist es vielleicht ist eine kombination aus beidem ich finde es aber auch blöd dass die
waffen keine richtigen namen haben ich mein lachmann was soll der scheiß warum heißt das ding nicht
heckler und koch mp5 sondern lachmann irgendwas 7 6 sonst was oder lachmann sub und sowas ist
das bescheuern ich mein lachmann ist ja wenigstens irgendwie noch gewissermaßen das hört sich so
halbwegs deutsch an ja aber ganz im ernst warum heißt das ding nicht heckler und koch mp5 anstatt
lachmann sub spart man sich jetzt auch deswegen haben wir drei gewähre namens lachmann da kommt
schon lachmann lachmann so kotzen ich könnte kotzen wenn ich daran denke dass es leute gibt die
indem sie skins kaufen dieses business modell auch noch unterstützen es macht mich so wütend es
macht mich so traurig ohne scheiß jetzt es kommt mir so vor als ob die sich hier bei cod vorgenommen
haben sich mit denen bei bettel vierten wettstreit zu liefern wer die eigene aber ich dachte spiel
auf dem pc spiel spiel auf der ps5 mehr hat er vorhin gesagt schneller in grund und boden
stampfen kann das kann doch nicht deren ernst sein sogar fucking hazard zone in 2042 hat mir
mehr spaß gemacht als das hier das hier ist für mich das schlechteste triple a game was ich
jemals gespielt habe und ich habe viele schlechte triple a games gespielt aber war so ein zweifel
free game free game nicht beschweren hier free game top echt alles ist top sogar fucking fallout 76
noch es ist kaputt als fallout 76 zum release das will schon echt was heißen das muss man
erstmal schaffen das ist ja so eines der eines der der standardsachen was leute gerne von solche
spiele sagen so nach dem motto warum legst du dich auf es ist doch kostenlos du musst es doch nicht
spielen und so was das das mag ja alles sein es steht ja keiner mit der pistole hinter dir und
sagt dir du musst das game jetzt spielen aber wenn du es spielst in dem spiel sachen drin sind die
dich abfacken dann fangen die dich ab egal ob du dafür bezahlt hast oder ob es kostenlos ist
hast du den aim assist für konsolen spiele angestellt ja das ist super super heftig in
in mw2 gibt es auch dieses video wo der typ sich dreht und quasi automatisch dann sein sein
fadenkreuz am gegner stickt ohne dass er richtig sein controller bewegt jaja der aim assist ist ultra
heftig das sound design von diesem game auch echt komisch damals original mw2 du konntest
sogar ohne wisst ihr wisst ihr wisst ihr was eigentlich richtig op wäre noch noch op als
auf der ps5 zu spielen wenn man mit chronos auf dem pc spielt dann hast du auf dem pc
bessere performance bessere auflösung besser bessere besseres alles plus du hast den aim assist
und kannst deine maus verwenden die bros spielen konsole naja moment die bros spielen controller
nicht unbedingt konsole aber aber total also das wirst du noch mal richtig op sein oder
chronos am pc nicht an der ps5 spiel du hast alles gehört hier in diesem game du kannst was weiß
ich wie viele audioeinstellungen durchgehen es wird nicht besser das stimmt ist du hörst du
hörst in dem du das stimmt tatsächlich du hast in warzone total viel aber nicht das worauf es
ankommt manchmal hörst du nicht dass einer hinter dir die treppe hoch läuft das ganz wir der sound
ist wirklich ganz weird champ wie scheiße und du hörst trotzdem nichts teilweise kann einer fünf
meter neben dir stehen und schießen du hörst es nicht ich weiß nicht was in diesem spiel kaputt
ist dass das so ist aber es ist leider so es geht mir so auf den sack das geht mir alles in diesem
game auf den sack aber das geht mir auch noch mal ganz besonders auf den sack du wirst genötigt mit
der arme sack und es klingt scheiße apropos scheiße ich weiß auch nicht wie man den a10 so
sehr wie in diesem game verkacken kann der war doch in warzone 1 mal gut was haben die damit
angestellt der ist jetzt noch mehr pingpong kanone als a10 ist das ist das der erstreck
der bf in gta ist sogar schlechter als der bf 2042 a10 im portal modus und er braucht gefühlt
zehn treffer um den infanteristen zu töten das kann doch nicht deren ernst sein der a10
ist so ganz schön 14 monat subscription massive aber falla zugeschlagen allgemein kommen mir die
kill streaks ziemlich nutzlos vor außer der drone ja uav trop total oft ich weiß ich ob das ein
bug war am anfang vielleicht sagt er das jetzt auch gefühlt in jeder zweiten kiste hatte ich
nur uav die drone ist halt einfach gott like und warum weil sie es einem deutlich schwieriger
gemacht haben an die eigenen klassen zu kommen die konnte man sich in warzone 1 ja noch bequem im
shop kaufen und zwar hat man sich ja das geht nicht mehr du kannst jetzt im shop kannst du erstmal
nur primary waffen kaufen und gadgets und sowas hast du dein zeug das war wunderbar an warzone das
war das was warzone gut gemacht hat man hatte zwar am anfang macht macht aber warzone 2 ein bisschen
battle royalliger zumindest den anderen ähnlicher random phase wo man halt loot gesammelt hat und
dann nicht unbedingt das hatte was man haben wollte aber spätestens so ab der mitte der runde hatte
ich genau das setup was man spielen wollte und konnte dann damit vernünftig spielen und alles
war gut nein hier muss man jetzt diesen pve dreck spielen um an die klassen zu kommen ja den
den ich am anfang gezeigt habe nicht bis zu den punkten mit dem juggernaut aber das stückchen
davor mit dieser nbc basis sehr wohl gratulation ganz toll und dann gibt es eine reihe von abwürfen
während der runde die könnte man dann einsammeln aber die kann halt jeder einsammeln ja und das
war es shop ganz vergessen kann sie nur deine eigenen waffen kaufen aber nicht die perks und
ohne perks bis auf der drohne also bis demma auf der drohne denkt da mal drüber nach entweder bist
du da oft auffällig weil du da oft auf der drohne bist oder muss diese pve kacke spielen um nicht
mehr auffällig zu sein bist aber währenddessen total auffällig und wirst wahrscheinlich von
einem anderen team weg gepusht und umgebracht während du die pve kacke machst gratulation
völlig hörnrissig genauso hörnrissig wie diese komischen neuen wandern dem konnte ich jetzt
irgendwie nicht ganz folgen die sie eingeführt haben was soll das denn bitte das hat sich doch
bestimmt irgend so ein kleiner wanderhoden bei denen bei cod ausgedacht wäre das ganz
teufel die zone dritte sich in drei teile und dann das fand ich auch erst mal sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig
zur mitte und machen eine zone hahaha und dann wird die kleine und dann wandert die in eine
zufällige richtung hahaha was soll das bringen wer hat darum gebeten niemand es bringt auch nichts
vielleicht soll es ja das kämpeln verhindern es erreicht aber doch das absolute gegenteil denkt
da mal drüber nach da sitzen dann welche am rand durch zufall genau da wo die zone hin wandert die
haben das ist eines der sachen die mir bei battle royale prinzipiell auf den sack geht dass du
einfach rum liegen kannst die ganze zeit ich erinnere nur mal daran habe ich schon ein paar
mal erzählt ich habe mal irgendwann den fehler gemacht und habe ein koreanisches pupke tournament
geguckt wo es auch nicht irgendwie um kills oder irgendwie sonst was ging sondern es ging wirklich
darum wer am ende die runde gewinnt und am ende die runde haben diejenigen gewonnen das war
glaube ich ein dreier oder vierer ich glaube sogar vierer team drei oder vierer team so und die
haben legit die ganze runde rumgegammelt im gras an irgendeiner mauer und am ende haben sie dann
zwei kills gemacht haben gewonnen und ich sage euch die caster die das casten mussten die haben
versucht hype zu generieren es war aber wirklich cringe anzugucken ja die haben die dann sonstige
dinger erzählen es ist getting intense ist getting intense und in wirklichkeit hat irgendein
typ gerade mal den feuer modus gewechselt oder sowas es war nichts es ist einfach eine viertel
stunde nichts passiert also das war keine sinnvolle sache das war wirklich ganz bescheid ja also das
ist halt so ein ding was ich an battle royale allgemein ein bisschen blöd finde was halt im
zweifelsfall aber an der map liegen kannst am ende den kill absnacken kannst der anderen seite man
kann das auch wirklich aktiv spielen guckt euch die ganzen warzone streamer an also ich habe mal
ich habe öfters mal bei schux damals reingeguckt gut das spiel auch konsole macht aber keine
unterschied die spornen also die springen vom fluchzeug ab kühlen erst mal acht leute weil
das halt meist ein super store oder irgendwas war wo in der wo halt viel los war keine ahnung
caldera habe ich nie gespielt und dann sind die permanent am rennen und flitzen über die map
und am leute kill also kannst das schon äußerst aktiv und ja fast schon fast schon tdm like spielen
muss da noch ein bisschen was auf die reihe kriegen ja aber du kannst halt auch abschimmeln bis zum
schluss wobei ich das halt langweilig als fack finde man du hast vielleicht dann am ende runden
wenn aber hast halt 30 minuten rumgelegt den perfekten campers pot weil alle anderen teams
genau zu ihnen kommen müssen weil das ja die richtung ist die am längsten aus dem gas raus
ist und dann können die die leute die dahin kommen perfekt abcampen und so gewinnt dann am ende ein
team durch zufälle einfach weil sie am richtigen spot war allein schon die runden nicht durch diesen
scheiß verloren habe es geht mir so auf den sack es ist so zum kotzen und es ist so traurig
und hirnrissig die bewährte lösung ist dass es zur mitte kleiner wird das ist fair in der mitte
möchte niemand sein und alle werden rausgetrieben aber nö ich hoffe das video hat euch gefallen
ob video ja also ich habe jetzt gelernt in dem video erfindet es scheiße mit vielen
punkten die ich so auch nachvollziehen kann ob man jetzt den entwickler wünschen muss dass
sie sterben naja man kann es auch übertreiben aber unterm strich ich kann es gut verstehen dass
ihm kein bock macht
die mz ist andere die mz habe ich tatsächlich genau eine runde gespielt und war höchst verwirrt was
bot sind und was gegner sind auf einmal habe ich den bot gekillt und es war ein gegner
was sie am kill feed siehst ja also was war das jetzt so was kann man sonst angucken haben
dann hier noch schönes reale irrsinn ärger mit installing mac os oder microsoft 22 minuten
alle wir können das wir können das wir können das überspringen skippen hochzeiten sind sein job so
arbeitet ein selbstständiger freier traurätner dachte eigentlich immer das lässt man irgendwelche
leute machen die man kennt die dürfen die großen reden reden schwingen gut mal davon abgesehen ich
würde nicht heiraten also das heißt ich habe das problem ursprünglich nicht aber auf der
anderen seite wenn dann würde ich doch jemanden machen lassen den ich kenne unabhängig davon ob
der das gut kann oder nicht dann wenigstens was persönliches aber irgendwie ist fast alles was
wir empfohlen kriegen nichts was mich interessiert die gucken die falschen videos leute oder der
youtube algoritmus verkackt kann auch sein aber sonst irgendwas die katastrophe namens meta verse
ich habe die kleinste serverrack gemacht ok das gucken wir uns mal schnell an was er da gebaut hat
alter resident sleeper ok mit so einem ssd things die displays die display kenne ich da so 0815
standard ssd 1360 sowas in der richtung ist das wahrscheinlich so das display eines der standard
dinger also es ist im prinzip ein 3d 3d gedrucktes gehäuse ok ok mal eine eine komplett bescheuerte
frage aber was ist der sinn überhaupt davon letztendlich ist ein raspberry pi drinne warum
muss ein raspberry pi in so ein fettes gehäuse beziehungsweise in so ein fettes rack es ist ja
kein rack kannst du das ding mal richtig richtig rein raus machen also was ist der sinn davon
wenn du kannst ein raspberry pi einfach in den alu gehäuse stecken dann bleibt der kühl
alles ist gut und im zweifelsfall machst du halt eine ssd dran und stellst ihn drauf kannst du
theoretisch unten noch mit irgend so einem taser power strip dran machen sieht nice aus ja das
stimmt wohl die led anzeige ist auch total unsinnig die braucht auch niemand sieht nämlich so aus als
steht da die ip drauf und muss mal kurz mal ein bisschen ip steht drauf ram usage disk usage
temperaturen braucht kein mensch wenn ich wissen will weil man raspberry pi im keller für eine
temperatur geh ich einfach bei ssh drauf und guckt das oder ich habe in den monitoring was
das überwacht also es sieht cool aus sinnvoll ist es nicht zumal das ganze auch auf jeden fall nicht
aktiv kühlen muss mit dem passenden case aber es ist cool aus das muss man ihm lassen
ok das ist cool der eine batterie mit drinnen ok wenn man eine batterie da noch irgendwie noch
irgendein akku noch mit reinlegt dann ist es tatsächlich so dass wird sie schwierig in so
ein raspberry case bekommen das muss es dann irgendwie draußen dran kleben und da hat vielleicht
auch sein media storage so let me show you how i made it ja 3d getrunken project came about
because when i've made up the case for my raspberry pi to house a ups then people have asked me to
add an ssd and when i've made one up for an ssd then people have asked me to add a ups the problem
is that both of these boards are designed to sit directly underneath the raspberry pi the ups
ob man den lüfter braucht ich weiß nicht ich glaube ein paar kühlripp ein paar kühllöcher
hätten es hätten es getan ja oben dass die warme luft raus kann unten das kalte luft
reinkommt also wenn das ding letztlich gerade auf 100 prozent läuft gerade der raspberry pi 4 wird
halt wenn er wenn er cpu last zieht oder wenn er cpu last hat relativ schnell war aber ob man
wirklich aktiv kühlen muss ich bin mir da sehr unschlüssig
gps because it uses these pogo pins to connect to the pies gpo pins and the ssd
because of the jumper to hook it up to the pies usb ports so that's got me thinking of a way to
mount all three on top of each other and the solution that came to mind is some sort of rack
mounting closure although these don't exist in sizes suitable for raspberry part so i decided to
design my own i designed the rack infusion 360 to look somewhat like a server act that would be
used for a typical home lab da bin ich ja viel zu unfähig für eigene sachen für 3d trucker zu
design hat es jemand von euch schon mal gemacht ich trucke ab und zu mit meinem 3d trucker zeug
aus ja beispielsweise letzten clips clips für für den hert für die dunst abzugshaube über
dem hert also für solche sachen ist der drehdrucker schon recht praktisch aber selbst sachen design
bin ich bin ich zu ppega für it's got a tinted acrylic swing door on the front and tinted acrylic
side panels or a chat is high IQ. The top, bottom and back are all solid panels with the back having a cable entry point and the top
having a 40 millimeter fan for cooling inside we've got space for three racks one for the pie
one for the ups and one for the ssd die perspektive sieht irgendwie nicht richtig aus oder die
perspektive das sieht viel zu breit aus ja i'm also going to mount an oled display alongside the pie
to provide some stats on resource usage on the server with the design done are 3d prints of the
parts in black PLA also das gehäuse hat bestimmt 18 stunden gedruckter
so those are all the components for the housing made up now we just need to add the racks to
it to hold the electronics
das ist ja nicht am block das ist ja einzelne dinge es geht vielleicht sogar aber es ist relativ viel
das hat auf jeden fall eine weile gedruckt man kann auch einfach jetzt mal seriously man kann
auch einfach eine stink normale sata ssd nehmen und dann mit dem usb adapter oder eine usb ssd was
wahrscheinlich die einfache variante ist als mit so einem ding und wahrscheinlich auch noch billiger
und performance technisch macht es beim raspberry pie keine unterschied mit 256 gig western digital
ssd
die ups i'm using is the power sugar 3 plus this has a 5000 milliampere battery
also ich habe für raspberry pie auch so eine mini usb das ist allerdings mit so einer ich
zeige euch das mal wie heißen diese batterien die in 8 7 die auch in e-zigaretten drin sind akku
18 die dinger war das stream gerade geleckt oder vorn macht wieder dinger also ich habe
so eine raspberry pie mini raspberry pie usb mit so einem akku drinne ubs
ne jetzt sieht anders aus lindschuh quinn grün alles klar
sieht sowas hier sowas sowas hier in der richtung ist das was ich hab sieht sieht
sieht ein bisschen anders aus was eine batterie reinsteckte das bei der usb und gut ist easy
sieht halt nicht so cool aus und nicht so schön quadratisch wie bei ihm
sieht quasi so ein bisschen aus so hier so sieht das so sieht das aus ziemlich ähnlich
ja ja dieses teil so so ähnlich sieht das sieht das aus damals schließt bei usb an
machst du auf der einen seite stecker stecker dran auf der anderen seite nicht stecker hier
machst du usb in und hier machst du usb out und das schaltet halt um wenn das ausfällt
geht genauso gut es sieht nicht so stylisch aus wie das ding
das kann man so nicht zwangsläufig sagen der raspberry pie hat nicht die besten
den besten output was also also hat glaube ich nur maximal 750 milliampere oder sowas
für die 650 für die usb outs outputs das reicht für einige ssd ist nicht und das führt dann
meistens nicht dazu dass es einfach nicht geht sondern dass es random immer mal wieder abkackt
oder die platte read only wechselt und sowas also da muss man gucken also wer stabilitäts
probleme mit seinem raspberry pie hat und das ding über den usb ssd betreibt der sollte mal in
die logs gucken ob die platte nicht read only geht und wenn sie das macht dann wahrscheinlich
weil die platte nicht genug strom bekommt und selbst wenn sich read only ist einfach wenn es
errors bei der platte gibt oder bei der ssd gibt dann liegt das höchstwahrscheinlich daran dass die
platte nicht mit genug saft versorgt werden kann aus den usb ports vom raspberry pie ist aber eine
schöne variante ist schön kompakt und und sieht sieht gut passend aus als schöner als so ein usb
ding was daneben hängt du kannst den output erhöhen aber musst du beim raspberry pie 4 nicht
mehr ich glaube das musstest du nur bei den alten bei dem 4er ist es so dass du maximal über die
port so und so viel ziehen kannst und da bringt ja auch eine konfig nichts und das reicht für
einige ssd ist nicht ja zum beispiel für diese für die für die ganzen sandisk usb dinger sandisk
ultra und hast du nicht gesehen usb 3 ssd ist 3.2 ssd usb 3.2 ssd reicht das nicht oftmals tritt
dann noch in kombination auf wenn du beispielsweise noch was anderes angeschlossen hast an usb dass
das der maximale output den du hast an usb pots nicht reicht mit ihren high iq dingern
sieht schon sieht schon recht clean aus gebe ich zu
selbst eine idee wenn es um einen konsolenserver für alle an geräte in einem rack geht ja kann ich
dir was zu sagen du willst kein konsolenserver oder gut vielleicht willst du konsolenserver wenn
du konsolenserver willst dann hast du ein rechten zentrum mit einem eigenen technikraum hast du
wahrscheinlich nicht du hast wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein rack da stehen mit ein paar rechnern auf
die du remote drauf zugreifen können möchtest du hast wahrscheinlich auch keine probleme wenn du
dort hinlaufen musst und vga und usb anstöpseln muss dann kauf sie dir nämlich einfach bei ebay
so eine
ja ist diesen dinger
spider wie heißen die teile ja ist bei spider nicht spieler spider
alter warum ist das so teuer
what the fuck
ich habe meine damals für 95 euro oder so gekauft ok ich habe nichts gesagt den kram gibt es
anscheinend gerade nicht nicht wirklich lieferbar ok kann sein dass es aktuell schlechter greifen
nichts gibt wie gesagt ich habe eine für 95 euro oder irgendwie so was in dem dreh gekauft und
musste mal gucken ob die irgendwo was irgendwo was sinnvolles finde ist ja das ist dann total
simpel du steckst das dran und usb an vga hier an der seite auf der anderen seite steckst du
das netzwerk dran oder gehst mit dem browser drauf und wisst ihr was das beste ist das
gerät kam irgendwann 2005 oder so auf den markt ja das ist uralt wir haben es ja im stream im
stream mal ausprobiert es gibt firmen update dafür dass du mittlerweile html 5 interface
hast du brauchst auch kein java mehr und so was aber aktuell ist es anscheinend nicht zu
bekommen wie es aussieht muss man gucken was es da sonst noch gibt ist aber wahrscheinlich
für dich die die bessere war ja gut da muss man als selbst ein bisschen was bauen was bauen
kann man kann man bestimmt auch mal ist wahrscheinlich für dich so die bessere lösung als wirklich
in diesem konsolenteil ins rack zu bauen braucht man daheim eigentlich nett
was wäre dann ein sinnvoller preis für ein rest of the pie model 4
kann ich aus dem kopf nicht sagen ich glaube ich glaube die 4 gigabyte variante kostet glaube
ich standardmäßig also das was ich der hersteller mal gedacht hat glaube ich 50 euro oder so oder
40 sogar nur oder was die 2 g variante aber gut ich meine letztendlich ist egal was ich
der hersteller bei gedacht hat die frage was ist bereit dafür zu bezahlen ist halt knappheit
schwierig überhaupt schwierig einzubekommen ob die aktuell welche haben ohne dass sie
in ihren komischen raspberry pie club club muss nur gibt nichts nix lieferbar
nix lieferbar hier
zum glück habe ich noch genug hier sowohl raspberry pie 4 als auch 0 2 0 w 2
der kram ist halt schon unsinnig teuer
149 euro sonst geht es euch auch noch gut und alter ist das teuer meine güte ich meine das 2g
modell das kann man sich das kann man sich vielleicht noch geben lieferzeit sieben wochen
sieben wochen ernsthaft für den raspberry pie ja schwierig da bin ich echt froh dass ich noch
welche habe die 2 flat patterns in inkscape laser cut you could also 3d print these trays
but it takes a minute to cut them both from acrylic rather than a few hours to 3d print them
so it's easier to make changes or adjustments if i need to
ach der hat ein laser cutter ja das muss der erst mal haben daheim
ich meine ich meine wer hat kein laser cutter da im grinch sieht aus wie
so ein lockenwickler ok wir skallen mal ein bisschen vor was denn da rauskommt
das display ist eigentlich nur show ist total unsinnig
ich verstehe dass das ein cooles projekt ist und das irgendwie ein gewissen show effect hat
aber der sinn von einem magic mirror erschließt sich mir wenig weil wenn du im bad bist hast du
eh dein handy dabei das was du auf dem magic mirror anzeigen lassen kannst ist ja in der
regel jetzt auch nicht so super detail reich dass es dir irgendwie großartig was bringt
höchstens vielleicht irgendwie temperatur und wetter oder so was aber das kuckst du
eh am besten auf dem smartphone nach und hast dann auch karte mit wolken und regen und sowas
also ich glaube die meisten überschätzen die sinnhaftigkeit oder der mehrwert eines magic
mir aus
wie siehst du am ende aus
doktor fern beste man hat lüfter oben und lüfter außen
ja die seite das war das war das war das alte gehäuse mit dem
ja so ist es doch deutlich schöner vor allem noctua leise noctua lüfter meine
dinger können ja auch nicht zaubern ich meine sieht ganz schick aus
ok das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein mehrwert von diesem usb bord wenn man da so zeit gesteuert
das ein und ausschalten mit machen kann das eigentlich ganz cool
man kann man auch easy mit anderen schaltbaren steckdosen leiste machen
ja optisch optisch ganz hübsch praktisch vielleicht teilweise brauchen tun man sich
wirklich macht aber was her lasse ich mir gefallen und ist bestimmt mit
sicherheit ein sehr schönes bastelprojekt und es wird einige stunden tage wenn ich
wochen gebraucht haben bis da was wirklich gutes bei rausgekommen ist
so was dauert ja immer länger als man denkt
überlege gerade einen alten gebrauchten server zu holen für nass medien wieder gaben
muss gucken was es für einer ist und wie alt es ist weil die dinger sind laut und die dinger
sind meistens relativ strom hungrig und sind auch nicht da gerade für gut geeignet sie daheim
stehen zu haben weil da ist nichts mit im eidel irgendwie lüfter runter drehen oder so was
gerade wenn du die alte beispielsweise hp server oder sowas holst oder irgendwie so ein dl3 80
generation irgendwas was gerade günstig auf ebay ist die dinger sind groß laut und verbrauchen
viel strom leistung haben sie mit sicherheit genug weil auch zehn jahre alte cpus für die
meisten sachen ohne probleme ausreicht aber die fressen halt massig strom sind heiß sind laut
gucken wir mal was sowas auf ebay gerade kostet gucken wir mal irgendwie so ein alter dl3 80
und hier kriegst du zum beispiel was für 50 euro aber das ist das hat genug leist
es frisst halt wirklich ordentlich strom
haben wir sofort wir machen man nur sofort kauf
aber hier für 150 euro oder hier noch noch ein älteren noch ein älteren
ihr kriegst den dl3 80 g5 ok das ist g5 ist wirklich alt g5 ist den würde ich mir nicht
mehr kaufen der ist wirklich alt was war da drinnen da sind noch da sind noch server aus
zeiten da habe ich hab da war ich fast noch zu wie das ist uralt g5 ja
von wann sind die cpus 2008 ja das ist wie gesagt das ist alt das ist ganz alt das würde ich
nicht mehr kaufen das ding das ist zu alt na gucken wir mal zwar das ding an was ist das für
einer g7 ja das ist was das dürfte preisleistung technisch ganz ok sein leistungs mäßig reicht
es auch komplett aus die dinger sind aber laut da darf man sich da keine illusion hingeben die
dinger sind sind laut aber ebay please die dinger sind laut die dinger sind auch nicht strom sparend
ist halt die frage ob sich das wirklich lohnt also ich da würde ich ehrlich gesagt lieber wenn
sowas in der richtung sein sollte ich meine du kannst die insofern hp micro micro server oder
sowas kaufen gibt es auch ab 679 euro ist halt nicht so super billig wie so ein gebrauchtes ding
haben auch keine hat auch keine außen liegenden hotswap raum
also ganz ehrlich gebrauchte server vielleicht findest du was halbwegs neues günstig eventuell
aber selbst heute sind sachen nicht ausgelegt für ja sowas hier sondern verkehrt aber wie gesagt
die sind auch heute nicht dafür ausgelegt strom sparen und leise zu sein das ist sogar halbwegs
modernes ding hier halbwegs modernes was ist denn da drin xeon ein da ist ohne cpu kann das sein
ist er ohne cpu
der ist ohne cpu oder sonst wird es sonst wird sie irgendwie drinstehen ja
tjo also ich ich bin da kein so großer fan von gebrauchten servan bei von ebay
die macht ja eigentlich bergab kleines nass also ich habe ich habe hier meine
kiste hinten in diesem mini surfer raum steht und ich ziehe da ab und zu mal die wichtigsten
dateien drauf und ich mache dann ganz simpel noob style eine externe platte in
ersund nachts fertig aus gar kein gar kein großes ding so was können wir uns jetzt noch
geben ihr zeigt mal ja die katastrophe namens meta verse uiuiui ok chat das gucke ich mir
jetzt mal an was ist das hier raspberry pie alternative mini pc home server refurbished
battlefield deal ein fujitsu fudro
von den dingen habe ich noch nie was gehört der preis ist schon mal echt ok
wurde das zellatten sound video schon geguckt ne
was haben wir da drin ok das ist low power intel plattform
das ist das ist durchaus in ordnung es ist ok damit reißt er keine bäume aus ja also die
anderen cpu sind die man es da vor angeht natürlich deutlich schneller das low power
intel wahrscheinlich quadcore wenn man glück hat in quadcore mal gucken ob das ein quadcore
ist oder nur in dual quadcore ja das geht und es ist wahrscheinlich relativ strom sparen also diese
plattform an sich braucht 6 7 watt eidl und gut da ist er noch ein bisschen mehr dran wahrscheinlich
braucht das ding eidl 11 12 watt 3 watt eidl das erscheint mir jetzt ein bisschen sehr wenig
das ist nicht schlecht kann man sich tatsächlich überlegen finde ich gar nicht mal so übel
preislich ist auch in ordnung also wenn man mit so was kleinem klarkommt warum nicht ein
raspberry pie ist natürlich noch ein bisschen kleiner aber ist schon ok hat es hat auf jeden
fall ein bisschen mehr rechenleistung als ein raspberry pie auch als ein vierer braucht
bisschen bisschen mehr strom wahrscheinlich aber man kann es halt kaufen was 3 watt das erscheint
mir sehr wenig zu sein also ich hatte auch mal so ein low power intel plattform die gleiche
glaube ich sogar es war halt ein srock bord es war kein bord was explizit für low power
gebraucht war das hat glaube ich 6 6 7 watt wenn ich alle powersachen powerspar sachen
eingeschaltet habe ich glaube sieben watt hat das gebraucht mit ssd ohne platten
warum haben server so viel eidl verbraucht aber gut die haben nicht nur viel eidl verbraucht
haben generell viel verbraucht weil die nicht dafür gedacht sind großartig irgendwie lüfter
runter zu regeln oder sonstige sachen zu machen die sind für dauerhaft betrieb ausgelegt das heißt
auch in dauerhafte lüftung dauerhafte klimaanlage und dementsprechend ist da halt der fokus was
anderes da legt keiner wert drauf dass die dinger sich schön runter tacken dass sie dass sie lüfter
runter drehen dass das irgendwie komponenten verwendet die wenig strom verbrauchen das kommt
mit der zeit muss man sagen ist jetzt schon ein bisschen besser geworden ja also gerade in der
heutigen zeit gucken natürlich auch rechenzentrum betreiber drauf auf stromkosten und server
hersteller schmücken sich natürlich auch ganz gerne mit unsere server sind super grün aber das
kannst du vergessen bei den älteren dingern da liegt einfach nicht der fokus drauf das ist nicht
dafür gebaut im rechenzentrum ist es ja auch egal ob das ding laut ist oder nicht das steht im
keller oder irgendwo im siebten stock oder sonst wo rum und kein interessiert ob das laut ist oder
warm ist oder sonst was ist das ist halt einfach da und arbeitet vor sich hin und soll möglichst
selten kaputt gehen habe ich eigentlich schon mal die story erzählt warum es bei mir auf der
arbeit kein rechenzentrum im keller gegeben hat warum das rechenzentrum irgendwie fünften stock
oder so gewesen ist wasser nee nee ganz ganz kurz ist auch ist auch ganz einfach ist auch
ganz einfach erklärt es ist ganz einfach erklärt weil man hätte die möglichkeit gehabt das
rechenzentrum im keller zu machen aber dort hatten irgendwelche leute vom vorstand ihren parkplatz
und dann hatte man die auswahl gibt man sehr viel geld aus und stellt das rechenzentrum
irgendwie in fünften stock oder kriegen die ihre parkplätze gestrichen und man macht das
rechenzentrum in keller da hat man sich natürlich dafür entschieden selbstverständlich gibt man
viel geld aus macht das rechenzentrum in fünften stock obviously meinung zu nukes als cluster für
kubanitas kann man machen aber ich sehe den anwendungsfall für einen home kubanitas cluster nicht wenn
du üben willst mach da kannst du aber auch ein paar vms nehmen wenn du üben willst ok ansonsten
würde ich mir hinterdenken warum du daheim überhaupt eine kubanitas cluster haben willst hast du schon
die neuen sikbi sticks die die jetzt auch so noch fad mit diesem neuen chip oder welche hast du da
noch dran also ich habe ja noch ein konbi 2 der ist ja mittlerweile ziemlich outdated ich meine
funktioniert ohne probleme und ich werde ihn auch so lange weiterverwenden bis er mal nicht
mal funktioniert aber die die neun sticks mit den neuen chips sollen er deutlich besser sein
auf was reichweite noch mal angeht
würdest du tun hast alles vm laufen lassen fragt das nicht im frinas forum die steinigen dich dort
aber ja natürlich kannst du das als vm laufen lassen aber fragt das nicht im frinas forum
die werden sie als nächstes erzählen dass du das ding auch nicht einschalten darf bevor
es cc ram hat und solche geschichten ja siehst du bist eine ganze ecke schneller ist das die mit
10 g warum heißt es eigentlich k8 es ist eine gute frage keine ahnung weil es eben die abkürzung
für kubernetes ich weiß auch nicht warum es k8 8 s ist es gibt ja auch k3 s also ist ja so quasi
so ein leitwein mini kubernetes kram warum warum es eine acht ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
warum dann acht dazwischen ist weil es acht buchstaben sind ist das wirklich so ok k uber
nähte es tatsächlich 5 hat da das wusste ich gar nicht dass die acht für achts achts character
sind so was kann man sonst noch angucken zeigt mal hier die katastrophe namens meta vers ja wir haben
uns ja letztens angeguckt dass sogar die leute die für meta also die die die entwickler von meta
verse dass sie ihr eigenes produkt nicht gerne verwenden was ja immer ein super hinweis darauf
ist dass es wohl ein sehr gutes produkt zu sein scheint wenn die entwickler es selbst nicht
verwenden wollen und da gab es ja letztens eine news dass die entwickler den kram selbst nicht
verwendet haben verwenden daraufhin hat irgendwie ein manager rumgeschrieben so nach dem motto ihr
müsst das produkt lieben was ihr entwickelt und die sollen es gefällig verwenden ist halt meiner
ansicht nach von der falschen seite betrachtet die leute programmieren ist weil sie geld dafür
bekommen nicht weil das ihre herzensangelegenheit wäre diesen shit zu programmieren dann würden
die was anderes machen und sie finden es wahrscheinlich scheiße und sie haben auch schon oft gesagt dass
es scheiße ist aber sie wollen es trotzdem haben und kann es ja keinen zwingen dazu irgendwas gut
zu finden mitte der 2000er gab es ein kleines browserspiel entwickelt vom jugendprogramm der
daimler ag mobile kids namens moki taun moki taun war eigentlich sehr ist das club club penguin
oder wie das hieß ähnlich zu hubbo hotel nur konnte man hier kein echtes geld investieren und
mafiöse strukturen aufbauen stattdessen war moki taun eher auf das vermitteln von kompetenz im
straßenverkehr fokussiert schwebende roboter konnten angesprochen werden und verteilten ein
wenig von der ingamewährung wenn man kurze fragen zu verkehrsregeln oder trivia beantworten konnte
wenn man genug von diesem geld gesammelt hatte ja und übrigens wisst ihr was man zu vr chat auch
sagen muss die vr chat entwickler benutzen ihr eigenes game und spielen ihr eigenes spiel was
schon mal ein großer hinweis darauf ist dass die entwickler dahinter stehen und dass es irgendwie
gewisserweise auch was ist was was man eben benutzen will allein schon das ist für mich ein großer
pluspunkt wenn die entwickler ihren eigenen kram spielen sich neue verkehrsmittel wie ein
skateboard freiwillig nicht weil sie gezwungen werden oder ein fahrrad kaufen mit dem man schneller
durch die zahlreichen räume navigieren konnte auch neue kleidung musik für den walkman oder
ein handy mit denen man mit leuten auf anderen karten schreiben konnte waren im sortiment moki
town war für mich eine dieser seltenen erfahrungen in denen wirklich alle sterne richtig standen ich
war im richtigen alter um von diesem konzept komplett begeistert zu werden also ich habe
damals mmos kreisel gekreidet zu zeiten als mmos noch multiplayer spiele waren und kein solo
questen und ich habe jahrelang nichts anderes gemacht und man könnte ja so weit gehen und zu
sagen mmos damals waren ja in gewisser weise eine art metaverse es kann ja eh keiner sagen wo das
mmo anfängt und wo das metaverse aufhört oder wo das metaverse einfach das mmo offen das ist
alles sehr schwammig und sehr fließend warum das jetzt auf einmal da gut weil der zuck gesagt hat
dass es so ist der neueste shit sein soll verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt eh nicht online welten wo
leute zusammen kommunizieren und sachen machen gibt es ja schon ewig wie gesagt ich habe
mmos gespielt anfangen 2000 angefangen mmos zu spielen anfangen 2000er und das war noch wirklich
du bist damit hunderten leuten teilweise im pvp gebiet rumgelaufen du hast du hast quest gemacht
pvm mission rates dungeons geschichten mal mit mehr mal mit weniger leuten und das ging ja du
hattest den chat du hattest theoretisch zwar keinen voice chat aber du hattest damals relativ viele
leute noch im teamspeak discord gab es ja noch nicht das war ja damals auch schon vieles von dem
was sie sich heute unter metaverse vorstellen kann ja heute keiner so genau sagen was man
darunter versteht das second life habe ich den halb drum nie verstanden aber das gab es auch
schon wahrscheinlich ist second life mehr metaverse als das facebook metaverse je sein wird und außer
dass der zuck jetzt das irgendwie ausgerufen hat als das nächste große tolle tolle teil und irgendwie
keiner so wirklich daran glaubt weil was man sich da anguckt ich meine das sieht ich wüsste nicht
wozu man es verwenden soll das einzige was was vielleicht also wer das vielleicht geil finden
könnte sind irgendwelche managener manager bvl business leute die sich denken ja online spiele
sind mir viel zu kindisch und viel zu viel zu unbusiness style jetzt haben wir das metaverse
das ist quasi das mmo für manager so weiß ich was sie sich denken ansonsten egal hören wir uns
mal das video an meine freunde egal ob interessiert an video spielen oder nicht waren hier regelmäßig
anzutreffen und es hatte in diesem kreis der für mich damals die ganze welt war ein merkbares
soziales gewicht eine teure garderobe ein voller fuhrpark beachtenswerte highscores in den
minispielen und eine bekanntheit in dieser kleinen isometrischen pixelstadt hatten nicht nur bedeutung
in diesem einen kleinen browser fenster sondern auch außerhalb in der wirklichkeit es war vielleicht
im ansatz sogar vergleichbar mit den sozialen auswirkungen von earthland rams dem online
rollenspiel das march und ganz springfield in einer folge der simpsons spielt seit etwa einem
jahr muss ich immer häufiger an moki town zurückdenken und an die idylle die es für
mich symbolisiert seit facebook vor etwas über einem jahr seinen namen in meta endete und den
kurswechsel des unternehmens hin zur entwicklung des ominösen meta verses verkündete komme ich
nicht umhin gewisse parallel hinzusehen vor acht jahren 2014 hat facebook den vr headset
hersteller oculus gekauft ein deal der damals noch hauptsächlich mit der sorge verbunden war
dass man in zukunft ein facebook account bräuchte um die brillen weiter nutzen zu können was von
facebook erst kategorisch ausgeschlossen wurde kam dann später trotzdem der was denn sonst
entpuppt sich diese übernahme aber als erster schritt für eines der teuersten und seltsamsten
unterfangen normalerweise würde man an dieser stelle erst mal die begrifflichkeiten klären
damit alle im selben das ist schwierig meta verse zu definieren was also ist das meta verse nur ist
die antwort war weitem nicht man kann es gar nicht wirklich erklärt etwas damit zu tun hat behauptet
ist zu wissen doch in wahrheit ist es ein terminologisches sonnenliegen rennen alle
reißen sich um diesen einen begriff und wollen dass das was sie bauen bald man glaubt dass man
es weiß aber wenn man es erklären soll dann weiß man es nicht der ursprung dieses begriff
liegt im science fiction roman snow crash von 1992 dort ist das meta verse ein virtueller
zufluchtsort vor der anarchie geplagten realität und mehr oder weniger das scheint der kleinste
gemeinsame nennner von all den umherfliegenden angeblichen metaversen zu sein ein virtueller
zufluchtsort für alle in einem äußerst unkonkreten werbevideo zu metas horizon worlds getaufte
metaversum ist die vielleicht noch greift das ist das ist das wo die leute alle keine beine
haben virtually hangout in perfect harmony was so gar nicht wie das internet klingt dass ich kenne
das meta verse und was es auch nicht ist weil das erste was passieren wird wenn du dich in so
einem game einlogg sind irgendwelche schreienden zwölfjährigen oder leute die dir auf den sack gehen
schlüsselfiguren wie mark zuckerberg als nichts geringeres als the next face of the internet
hat der typ erzählt viel wenn der tag lang ist diese unbestimmtheit diese wachheit die diesem
begriff innerwohnt ist vielleicht auch seine größte stärke nur so kann gewährleistet sein dass jeder
der finanziell und oder emotional stark in das aktuelle internet investiert ist glauben kann dass
es eine rosige zukunft für einen selbst wird doch was investitionen angeht läuft es gerade beim
vorzeigeprodukt horizon worlds von ehemals facebook horizon worlds ist das game was schlechter aussieht
als in den wii spiel als rosig in 2022 sein aktuellen quartalsbericht vorgelegt und der
ist nun ja ziemlich katastrophal der gewinn des konzerns sank im vergleich zum vorjahr um 52
prozent der umsatz um 4,4 prozent reality labs die division von meta die für die entwicklung
des metaverses zuständig ist verschlangen allein in diesem dritten quartal 3,67 milliarden dollar
bei einem umsatz von 285 millionen dollar und das liegt nicht allein daran dass die inflation die
kaufkraft was wollen die auch aktuell verkauft sondern zu einem großen teil auch daran dass
ceo mark zuckerberg horrende summen in dieser eine große wette steckt und das tut er in einer
geschwindigkeit und masse die marktanalysten selbst für die standards des silicon valleys als
furchterregend beschreiben im august 2021 als meta noch facebook hieß war ein firmenanteil noch
etwas über 380 dollar wert ganz facebook als unternehmen hatte eine marktkapitalisierung von
über einer billion dollar keine amerikanische billion eine deutsche billion mittlerweile sind
von dieser 13 stelligen summe noch 240 milliarden übrig da zuckerbergs eigenes vermögen zu einem
großteil auf seinen 350 millionen anteilen an dieser aktie aufbaut ist auch sein geldspeicher
durch diesen crash von 125 milliarden auf 37 milliarden dollar oder der arme das ist in
anbetracht geopolitische muss ja bald unter die brücke mann noch außerordentlich schlecht so sehr
sogar das meta einst auf platz sechs mittlerweile nur noch auf platz 32 der wertvollsten unternehmen
der welt ist hinter samsung und kostco und diese zahlen dieses engstirnige verfolgen dieser
unkonkreten idee mag die frage aufwerfen ob mit mark noch alles in ordnung ist aber ich würde
behaupten gerade bei ihm gerade bei meta ist dieses verhalten noch am ehesten nachzuvollziehen
im april 2021 passiert etwas dass facebook den boden unter den füßen wegreißt ihn
unmissverständlich klar macht wer die zügel in der tech branche in händen hält das ios privacy
update sorgt dafür dass nutzer von iphones und ipads fortan durch ein kleines banner gefragt
werden ob ihre nutzerdaten an die gerade geöffnete app übermittelt werden sollen oder nicht das
problem für facebook hierbei abzulehnen ist im gegensatz zu einem cookie banner genauso leicht
wie anzunehmen auf facebooks geschäftsmodell basiert nun mal fast ausschließlich auf das verteilen
von werbeanzeigen basis von nutzerdaten über nacht ist facebook also urplötzlich bei einem
großteil seiner zugriffsgeräte blind und dementsprechend in seiner effektivität
oder arme zuckerberg stark der tut mir richtig leid hier dieser schock diese
verlorene machtdemonstration drängt den konzernen eine ecke alles was bleibt ist
eine umgebung selbst zu entwickeln in der man alle zügel in händen hält oder wie
zuckerberg ist letzten monat im investorenpunkt klingt das nachvollziehbar innovative dinge
entwickeln wenn man mehr von allem selbst kontrolliert und nichts anderes ist das meta
verse ein ort an dem alle drei variablen einen einzigen konzern gehören nicht nur ich hoffe
es gibt die neue ea ab dann auch im meta verse sammeln und auswerten von verhaltensdaten es
hat auch noch obrigkeit darüber wie und was im meta verse bezahlt wird und was das meta verse
eigentlich beinhaltet es ist nicht zwangsläufig überzeugung von einem konzept die diesen neuen
unternehmenskurs antreibt wie auch scheint ja kaum eins zu geben es ist eher die befürchtung dass
nichts anderes das eigene unternehmen vor der virtuellen bedeutungslosigkeit retten kann und
das erklärt warum ausschließlich hochrangige meta angestellte begeisterung für diese idee
ja das habe da habe ich mich ja schon darüber ausgelassen das sind dann die die ihren
entwicklern erzählen du musst halt an unsere vision glauben und wenn fragen die ja welche
visionen das können sie ihnen auch nicht sagen laut internen dokumenten des vice president
of meta verse nutzen selbst die leute angestellt das kennen wir schon da habe ich jetzt schon öfter
das was zugesagt wurden um das meta verse zu entwickeln das produkt kaum es heißt es würde
große qualitäts und performance probleme geben und trotz allem hätte horizon worlds noch kein
beweis für eine markt tauglichkeit erbracht zu recht vielleicht braucht den scheiß einfach auch
keiner dass sich die leute da draußen für das meta verse interessieren werden wenn es nicht mal
ihre schöpfer können in einer memo an seine angestellten schreibt er sie sollen es sich zur
aufgabe machen sich in das meta verse zu verlieben das haben wir den post haben wir schon angeguckt
spaß oder es gibt ärger und auch außerhalb der belegschaft von metas milliardenloch gibt es
eigentlich an der stelle das ist was was vielen männerchen ja irgendwie abgeht an dieser stelle
müsste man sich jetzt eigentlich fragen wer ist das wo liegt denn eigentlich das problem ist das
problem wirklich die entwickler oder meine vision also woran woran wohl woran hängt an der vision
oder dass meine entwickler keinen bock haben oder müsste er sich an der stelle wahrscheinlich
eingestehen da meine vision ist vielleicht nicht so das was die welt gebraucht hat aber das geht
ja nicht begeisterung aktuell hat horizon worlds nach angaben des unternehmens knapp 200.000
monatlich aktive nutzer ach das kann man schon benutzen 0 0 0 5 prozent von den 3,7 ach das kann
man schon benutzen und warum sollte man das benutzen 7.000.000 wie viel hat er noch kurz steam charts
vr chat man so viel haben die nicht aber wie sieht das so aus ja ziemlich ziemlich steady oder hier
ziemlich im prinzip immer immer mehr geworden hier immer konstant mehr eigentlich eines der
wenigen spiele die ich so einen kraft wo ich so einen kraft hier gesehen habe normalerweise ist
es eher peak bei release und dann runter und vielleicht zwischen aber hier das selten so
einen kraft zu sehen nutzern auf metas übrigen plattform zum vergleich second life das metaversum
von 2003 sozusagen hat auch 200.000 nutzer das spielt noch jemand und diese internationale
zurückhaltung in bezug auf diese virtuelle parallelwelt ist auch ziemlich verständlich
kaum etwas in metas oder anderen kleineren projekten hat bisher den eindruck erweckt dass
hier etwas mit substanz und mehrwert entsteht aktuelle metaverse projekte sind geplagt von
technischen fehlern stark veralteter grafik und so verursacht durch einen mangel an effektiven
konsequenzen ich meine dieses bild also warum man das gepostet hat das kann ja wirklich nur
realitäts realitätsferner kann man nicht sein irgendwelche billigst assets da rein importiert
und drumherum ist halt nix was was soll uns das sagen überhaupt und schon jetzt sind diese projekte
stark und schonungslos durch monitor ich verstehe übrigens auch nicht warum das so teuer ist
klub von metas horizon worlds applaudieren will der muss dafür mit echtem geld zahlen
was warum es ist für mich wirklich schwer mich in einen der wenigen menschen hinein zu
versetzen der ehrliche vorfreude für das metaverse empfindet klar es könnte so sein wie mokitown
damals für mich war nur halt im vr und globaler und mit der möglichkeit dass lucas rieger seine
nfts ausstellen kann aber eine über die realität gestülpte virtuelle parallelwelt die in den händen
eines der furchtbarsten unternehmen der welt ist es gibt optimistischere dystopien die idee
einfach alles virtuell nachzustellen kommt zudem zu einem zeitpunkt an dem immer mehr leute ihre
eigene zeit am bildschirm und im internet bewusst verringern und das metaverse in dieser form nur
als monopol ganz davon abgesehen ich will die echte welt doch gar nicht im spiel haben echte
welt habe ich doch genug sozialen implikationen promo videos der ganze bisherige sinn ich will
in dem mittelalter fantasy welt haben oder so was aber ich will doch nicht frankfurt mir dann
virtuell angucken das reicht mir echt schon wird die sich dafür ernsthaft interessieren werden
und ein monopol wäre zwar schlecht aber es ist auch genauso unwahrscheinlich wenn es ein metaverse
irgendwann mal zu erfolg schafft dann werden es gleich mehrere tun aber dank netzwerkeffekt
dank fehlenden monopol wird es auch keine neue welt geben in der man soziale außergewöhnlichkeit
erreichen kann denn es wird immer den einen kollegen geben der lieber das andere metaverse
nutzt um low poly business meetings am pixel strand abzuhalten erst war ich traurig aber
mittlerweile bin ich glaube ich ganz glücklich darüber dass es mokitaun nicht mehr gibt dass
es kaum noch bildmaterial davon gibt meine erinnerung daran hauptsächlich aus nostalgischen
gefühlen bestehen und ich keine also ich werde ich werde im december wieder da auch auf dem
freestand spielen so viel kann ich euch schon mal sagen ich mache jeden neuen freestand mit
für ein paar monate einfach immer noch bestes mmo ziemlich sicher wenn nicht nur meine freunde
sondern wirklich jeder damals in mokitaun gewesen wäre dann hätte ich vermutlich gar keine
erinnerung mehr daran
frankfurt bahnhofsviertel virtuell das lecker frankfurt bahnhofsviertel ist wie gesagt ein
echt schon kacke weil weiß nicht warum ich da virtuell hingehen sollte die erste nuke
in warzone 2 gibt es eine nuke ach ja das ist diese geschichte mit wenn du wenn du fünf
games gewonnen hast und dann irgendwie irgendwie sowas in fünfer win streak und dann muss noch
irgendwas machen haben wir uns heute von level cap jebaiten lassen nein wir haben uns noch nicht
von level cap jebaiten lassen aber da gab es auch nichts gibt nichts was level cap uns jebaiten
kann no pass kein level cap jebait heute abzock an der haustür overwatch 2 is a new low in gaming
ich weiß nicht ob ich in overwatch 2 angucken will battlefield 1 ist zurück und geht gerade
richtig ab ja das habe ich mitbekommen hat mich hat mich auch sehr verwundert hier steam charts
was macht okay eine sache muss ich die üblichen verdächtigen das mal kurz schauen also new world
ihr werdet sich glauben leute new world hat relativ viele spiele aktuell aber das liegt
nicht daran dass sie irgendwie super krasses zeug gemacht haben also viele ja immerhin die
haben einfach quasi so eine art neue season gestartet die haben neue server rausgebracht
und das ist generell das beste was du als mmo machen kannst neustarts regelmäßige
die leute mögen einfach neue server neue charaktere kreiten und alles okay 2042 ist mal wieder
ziemlich im arsch aber in zwei tagen geht die neue season online das werden wir uns auf jeden fall
angucken und was macht denn steam charts battlefield 1 null geil guck mal 28.000 leute 24 stunden peak
versus 5000 da liegen einfach irgendwie fünf jahre oder so zwischen den games und ist das neuste
tja es erlauben gescheites game im vergleich zu 2042 halt ein game mit detail und liebe gemacht
und nicht so ein hingeklatscher krab was möchte youtube eigentlich von uns da oben achso weil
fußball heute juckt mich überhaupt nicht als die leute sagen so nach dem motto ja wm in katar
muss man boykottieren und ich denke mir so ich habe noch nie großartig wm geguckt generell
fußball geguckt ich muss da nichts boykottieren ich hätte es auch so nicht geguckt
bis oft in flammen warum ist ubisoft in flammen ubisoft entwickelt aber haben fallt okay warum
ist ubisoft in flammen ist das von moris guck mal wem das ist moris guck ich immer gern aber
das streamt ja hauptsächlich einer der größten publisher auf dem spielemarkt und hat besonnen
es ist dings hier den den die stürme kenne ich wer ist das von denen das mit seinen open world
serien ganze genre geprägt das ist nicht die mitri das ist der andere das ist der der echt
keine ahnung das unternehmen gleich über jahre hinweg immer wieder überraschungen im großen
und kleinen probierte mit kleinen marken wie welly and hearts oder child of light neue gameplay
konzepte aus steht aber natürlich auch für große namen mit ja das ist fritz genau chat ja
bricht farkai und assassin's creed ist auf der stufe die von millionen spielern geliebt heißt
diskutiert und vor allem gespielt wurden doch in den letzten jahren sorgte der konzern auch
mit sexismus skandalen für schlagzeilen und enttäuschte mittlerweile ist ja fast so sagt
immer einen großen publisher wo es doch kein sexismus skandal ist ja wirklich der wahnsinn
mittlerweile gut ich mein blizzard hat es wie immer wieder von allen auf die spitze geht
mit soviel formelarbeit und zu wenig haben es wieder übertreiben haben sie übertrieben
produzierte auch einige rohr krepierer mal verrannte man sich beim versuch auf aktuelle spiele
hey ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie das hieß dieses ui sov bettel royal es gab es es gab
nee wie ist das noch mal scape irgendwas mit scape
wie ist das mal ein ui sov hyper scape hyper scape genau gibt es das noch
da steht unten links ein stil links lul hyper scape kacke und ist das spiel down
ach das wurde eigentlich jetzt komplett eingestellt ok ok ok
aufzuspringen dann zogen sich die entwicklungen anderer projekte teilweise ewig in die länge
und wiederum andere spiele haben es nicht mal bis zum release geschafft oder wurden vorher noch
stark umgebaut wir haben mal versucht uns einen überblick zu den aktuellen sorgen kindern von
ubisoft zu verschaffen und sind bei einer erschreckend langen liste aus ubisoft spiele
du brauchst türme die du erobern kannst du brauchst irgendwelche riesigen maps gefüllt mit kisten und
unsinnigen sachen also die ubisoft spiele sind schon sehr ähnlich aber türme türme ist das allerwichtigste
die komplett eingestellten spiele die spiele die wohl große probleme in der entwicklung haben und
türme die tatsächlich rausgekommen was macht eigentlich das neue siedler sollte da nicht ein
neues siedler sogar kommen irgendwann die letzten jahre über und kam glaube ich bis heute nicht auch
gleich wieder untergegangen sind fangen wir mit den eingestellten spielen an vor über
einem jahr kündigte ubisoft mit ghost recon frontline einen neuen free to play shooter an
irgendwo zwischen battle royale und klassischem arena shooter wollte man die marke nach dem open
world sprung von wildlands und im blut shooter breakpoint habe habe ich für breakpoint nicht
sogar werbung gemacht ich habe für breakpoint werbung gemacht ja nun für ein noch größeres
publikum öffnen nämlich die battle royale crowd was kann da schon schief gehen in spielmodus mit
102 spielern die in teams von je 102 wahrscheinlich weil es schon ein anderes game gab das 101 spieler
hatte und man wollte sagen das größte battle royale aller zeiten treffen sowie eine kleinere 9 gegen
9 spielvariante das ganze sollte stetig ausgebaut werden und regelmäßig das sieht so langweilig
schon aus im sommer 2022 gab die führungsetage von ubisoft jedoch in einem körtalsbericht bekannt
dass die entwicklung komplett eingestellt wurde das sieht so uninspiriert und langweilig aus war
aber auch nicht gerade gutes feedback durchgesickert derzeit unsichere wirtschaftliche lage habe es
dann laut ubisoft erfordert die entwicklungskräfte auf andere projekte zu bündeln frontline war
damit geschichte im gleichen körtalsbericht ich frage mich immer wie das als entwickler sein muss
wenn man wirklich mal als entwickler echt an dem spiel arbeiten mitgestalten kann vielleicht was
man persönlich super findet und irgendwie sich da also wenn es wenn man wenn man es halt so machen
kann wie ich am anfang gesagt habe bei einem der letzten videos hier wenn man wirklich mal ein
spiel machen kann was man selbst gerne spielen will mal angenommen man ist da wirklich ein
bisschen investiert und sieht es nicht so rein als ja ich mache halt das was irgendein typ sich
ausgedacht hat ich krieg da halt mein geld für ich frag mich wie das ist wenn dann einfach das
game an dem du dann irgendwie drei jahre gearbeitet hast eingestellt wird bestimmt auch kein allzu
tolles gefühl so nach dem motto ja drei jahre umsonst segte ubisoft auch eine vr umsetzung von
splinter cell ab die befand sich seit 2020 in der entwicklung und sollte exklusiv für die vr
brillen des facebook konzerns meter erscheinen video material gab es zu diesem projekt noch
genauso wenig wie eine klare gameplay beschreibung scheinbar wusste ubisoft mal wieder nicht so
richtig was die fischer anfangen sollten das hat ja leider seit jahren tradition und jeder
neue auftritt des agenten in irgendeinem mobile ableger wird nur noch entkräftet belächelt
frontline und splinter cell vr waren aber nicht die einzigen eingestellten spiele im selben
quartalsbericht wurde auch bekannt gegeben dass zwei bisher unbekannte titel ebenfalls auf eis
liegen über die beiden spiele sind bislang keine informationen an die öffentlichkeit gedrungen
aber das kann sich in den nächsten jahren sind alle so langweilig und nur lacht 15 aus irgendwie
also video wird euch präsentiert von den games da pc in kooperation mit boost box die bones
jahren aber mit unveröffentlichten viel kürzeres placement als ich gedacht habe kommen wir zu den
noch unveröffentlichten spielen die tatsächlich immer noch in der mache sind in den letzten jahren
aber mit vielen problemen zu kämpfen hatten und welches spiel passt auf diese beschreibung besser
als scale and bones eigentlich endlich 2022 rauskommen sollte und nun wieder verschoben wurde
diesmal auf märz 2023 das wurde voll klar das wurde schon vor vor ewigkeit einverkündigt
werkelt ubisoft singapur schon an der freibäuter simulation mit multiplayer focus gab es nicht
sogar mal ne beta zwischendurch schiffskampf oder war das was anderes wir uns hier gegenseitig die
kanonen kugeln in einer open world um die segelmasten ballern aber schon die vielen
verschiebungen seit der ersten ankündigung deuten darauf hin dass der kutter schon mehrmals zu
kentern drohte berichten zufolge durch lief scale and bones bereits mehrere reboots weil das
entwicklerteam selbst immer wieder konzepte verwarf hinzu kommen probleme mit der staatlichen
förderung in singapur ubisoft erhält zwar finanzielle unterstützung muss dafür aber
auch bestimmte deadlines einhalten und kann andererseits auch nicht einfach das ganze
projekt einstampfen scale and bones muss also rauskommen aber sorgt das spiel bislang vor allem
für skeptik die gameplay mechaniken wirken schlicht zu dünn für ein langfristig motivierendes
erlebnis dass sowohl solo als auch im koop und im pvp funktionieren soll und wahrscheinlich hat
man sich schlicht ergreifen total übernommen eigentlich für november gesetzt waren verschob
ubisoft scale and bones kürzlich dann noch mal um mehrere monate die zweifel am projekt wurden
dadurch definitiv nicht kleiner trotzdem sind wir mal gespannt was da im märz 2023 tatsächlich
wenn wenn überhaupt was rauskommt spiel bis dahin nicht noch mal vom kurs abkommt vor inzwischen
schon über 5200 tagen stellte ubisoft den ersten teaser trailer zu beyond good and evil 2 online
die fortsetzung des kult hits von 2003 befindet sich damit inzwischen tatsächlich länger in
der entwicklung als die nukem forever dieser traurige rekord dürfte aber aber nicht länger als half
life 3 geringsten probleme des spiels sein erstmals 2008 angekündigt waren infos zu
beyond good and evil 2 lange zeit rar gesät auf der e3 2017 tauchte es dann aber plötzlich
wieder auf und überraschte mit äußerst ambitionierten plänen im gegensatz zum
vorginger soll das heißt sie haben nichts dafür gemacht außer ein trailer erstellt
die uns komplette sonnensysteme zum erkunden eröffnet inklusive landungen auf planeten und
prozedural erstellte megastädte ok und was hat man davon gesehen einen trailer schafft immer
sehr großes vertrauen da drin laufen ist dann scheint die diagnose einfach ubisoft hat sich
schlicht übernommen seit 2019 gab es zwar immer wieder mal kleine lebenszeichen vom spiel
offizielle infos was nun sache ist fehlen aber laut gerüchten soll beyond good and evil 2 aber
mittlerweile ganz anders aussehen aber immer noch weit von einer fertigstellung entfernt sein einer
der bekanntesten schöpfer des originals michelle also hat ubisoft schon von einer ganzen weile
verlassen ob beyond good and evil 2 tatsächlich noch rauskommt steht also da wo das spiel hin will
in den sternen so richtig schlau sind wir aus avatar frontiers of pandora bisher noch nicht
geworden daher kam auch die release verschiebung im juli 2022 nicht wer wer hat bitteschön auf
ein avatar game gewartet besonders überraschend bis dahin gab es nämlich nur einen vollwertigen
trailer in vermeintlicher spielgrafik der war eigentlich nicht viel über das spiel verriet mal
abgesehen vom setting der ego perspektive und dass wir auf seiten der navi spielen also der
bewohner von pandora ich mein es passt eigentlich ganz gut wollte ich gerade sagen es passt ganz
gut weil es irgendwie demnächst wieder einen film gibt die sich gegen die ausbeutung durch die
menschen wären das hat zwar dank snowdrop engine die wir ja aus der division kennen bild hübsch
aus aber was man in der open world als blaues alien alles tun kann blieb bisher größtenteils
offen wie interagieren flora und fauna miteinander was für eine story wird hier erzählt wie sieht
das progression system aus keine ahnung kein wunder also dass ubisoft das spiel vom entwickler
team massive auf einen unbestimmten termin zwischen 2023 und 2024 verschoben hat läuft
ja wirklich gut bei ubisoft diese release verschiebung ich wollte gerade sagen was macht man
ohne scheiß schreiker ich wollte gerade ähnlich was ähnliches sagen wahrscheinlich wirst du
türme erobern weil im december ja auch ein neuer avatar film ins kino kommt und sich so eine tolle
synergie ergeben hätte hoffen wir dass frontiers of pandora durch die zusätzliche entwicklungszeit
mehr wird als eine zugegebenermaßen wunderschöne tech demo oder das nächste 0815 open world spiel
bei dem wir eigentlich nur eine von missionssymbolen folge knallte karte und türmen und türme
türme ganz wichtig dass ubisoft ein weiteres sorgen kind bei ubisoft ist das remake von prince
of persia the sense of time da kam schon der erste das soll remake werden die neuauflage
wirkte besonders bei der grafik stellenweise völlig veraltet egal ob charakter modelle
animationen oder texturen alles schien mindestens zwei klassen unter dem sonstigen ubisoft standard
laut anonymen quellen hatten die beiden noch vergleichsweise unerfahrenen indischen
entwickler studios von ubisoft auch zu wenig unterstützung von anderen teams bekommen das
negative feedback auf den ersten trailer und die probleme in der entwicklung führten gleich zu
mehreren verschiebungen inzwischen gibt es gar keinen neuen termin für das spiel das aber
wahrscheinlich wird es da eingestellt ubisoft montreal das studio hinter dem 2003 original
hat nun die leitung des projekts übernommen ob damit aber eine veröffentlichung im nächsten
jahr gesichert ist wissen wir nicht ubisoft hat aber schon gesagt dass die anderen serienteile
vorerst keine neuauflage bekommen sollen die siedler ja befindet sich schon das interessiert
mich was ist denn da eigentlich draus geworden länger in einer identitätskrise also bereits die
hatten doch schon vor drei jahren oder so neues neues gezeigt aber das gab es dann nie frühere
ableger schwanken zwischen den genres und mussten sich immer wieder neu erfinden während sich die
ersten spiele der serie der klassischen aufbau strategie verschrieben kamen später echtzeit
strategie ab dem ab dem dreier konntest du ja dann deine deiner soldaten und und du konntest ja steuern ich
als siedler 2 habe ich damals wirklich rauf und runter gespielt und auch das letzte war gar nicht
so schlecht das war zwar recht recht anders das was war das war das siedler 7
nee oder
oder 6
nee 8
ich glaube ich mein 7 ja das war das doch das war gar nicht übel das hat schon spaß gemacht
aus den überresten des gescheiterten die siedler 7 bastelte entwickler blubreit sogar mit
dann war es nicht sieben dann war es sechs ich weiß es nicht dass das mit dem mit mit dem weiblichen
protagonistin ja oder was war das siedler keine ahnung welches das war das fand ich übel das
hat echt das hat echt spaß gemacht also die kampagne das habe ich ja nie gespielt
seit wann ich auf twitter schon lange pions of anteria einen halbgaren rollenspiel art x mix mit
teil 8 wollte man dann wieder zurück zum ursprung so richtig mit gemächlichem spieltempo und
detailreicher darstellung von produktionszyklen in der theorie eine gute idee doch irgendwas ging
während der entwicklung schief der release wurde von 2019 auf 2020 und dann auf eine unbestimmte
zeit verschoben ok so sieht es also aus sie haben scheinen die verantwortlichen schnell bei einer
lösung zu sein wie wäre es mit ein bisschen echtzeit strategie anfang 2022 tauchte das spiel
jedenfalls in einer spielbaren beta wieder auf also ich finde das hat null siedler style die
grafik die stieß allerdings sofort bei fans und presse auf reichlich kritik das gameplay war
schlicht zu hems ärmlich gerade im vergleich zur internationalen konkurrenz schon nach wenigen
partien verpuffte jedwede variance und endete in gleichförmigkeit ubisoft ganz im ernst also ich
will den kram doch auch nicht wegen multiplayer spielen also ich meine es ist cool also am besten
am meisten bock hat mir damals immer noch gemacht wenn man multiplayer gespielt hat siedler 2 das
wird heute wahrscheinlich keiner mehr kann sich da wahrscheinlich keiner mehr einversetzen aber was
mir mega bock gemacht hat damals war siedler 2 split screen mit zwei mäusen am gleichen pc das
waren sachen die haben games damals unterstützt konnte es quasi mit zwei spielern am pc spielen
split screen mit zwei mäusen das war mega nice als alt gegen npc ist ja asche kritik und rückte
erst mal von einer veröffentlichung im jahr 2022 ab seit der beta katastrophe versucht das
entwicklerteam nun am rts konzept zu feilen aus der einst geplanten hallo ist auch von ubisoft ja
mittlerweile die rückkehr wird aber wohl nichts mehr ursprünglich war aber anno glaube ich war
wie hier die sunflower games oder so sam sunflowers ja das war mal das war mal nur die die ursprünge
mittlerweile ist aber alles ubisoft und dann gibt es ja auch noch x-defiant ein free to play shooter
der schon nach der ersten ankündigung 2021 viel kritik kassierte habe ich nicht voll mitbekommen
modisch schien für viele die formel aus arena shooter klassenfähigkeiten und zwei mäuse an
einem pc ja du konntest damals dass das war eigentlich wirklich da ist siedler 2 split screen
zwei mäuse ja genau so sah das dann aus du musstest zwei mäuse anschließen seriell
serieller port nicht usb leute serial port please ja serial port zwei mäuse und dann konnte einer auf
der linken seite spielen einer auf der rechten seite spielen und das damals das damals natürlich
auf in einem kleinen crt also 1024 mal 768 wenn es hoch kam ja so sah das aus
das ist aber deutlich mehr als man damals gesehen hat irgendwie hätte ich übelst bock drauf mal
wieder
wisst ihr das ist auch eines der coolen sachen an pixel grafik so pixel grafik veraltet irgendwie
nicht richtig das sieht immer noch ganz brauchbar aus
oh mann ja
ich erinnere mich noch dunkel und das war schwer also die kampagne war damals also fand ich damals
wirklich schwer style für möglichst diverse skins die man später als mikrotransaktionen
verkaufen kann noch dazu trug der flippige shooter den namen tom clancy weil hier
verschiedene fraktionen aus ubisoft mittlerweile heißt ja bei den alles tom clancy der typ hat
ja die namensrechte verkauft vor 20 jahren oder so seitdem gibt es ja da alles tom clancy sofa
tom clancy's klo tom clancy's go streaken tom clancy's warfighter tom clancy's also alles tom
clancy das miss viel besonders den sprinter tom clancy's ano 1800 die seit jahren keine richtige
fortsetzung bekommen sondern nur halbgarre referenzen die folge auf zahlreichen social
media kanälen regnete es negative kommentare und scheinbar ist auch ubisoft aufgefallen dass
der name des verstorbenen us-autors hier nicht unbedingt angebracht ist vor ein paar monaten
verschwand der zusatz tom clancy jedenfalls von allen werbeauftritten seitdem heißt das
spiel nicht mehr tom clancy's ex defiant sondern einfach nur noch ex defiant wie es um das spiel
selbst steht lässt sich derzeit aber nicht wirklich einschätzen man kann sich zwar für
geschlossene testläufe registrieren eine öffentliche beta wird es aber wahrscheinlich frühestens 2023
geben falls das projekt überhaupt noch final umgesetzt wird ubisoft müsste jedenfalls einen
ist der was bei solchen gameplays immer witzig ist wenn ich das sehe wahrscheinlich frühestens
2023 geben dass ist halt dass das gescriptet ist der dude weiß halt jetzt 23 der aim dahin ja
der weiß jetzt er läuft da genau rein das zufälligerweise laufen immer den gleichen
final umgesetzt wird ubisoft müsste jedenfalls einen deutlich besseren zweiten eindruck mit dem
das eigentliche schwierige alle headshots wenn die gegner normalen muven da musst du nicht nur
predikten wo die hin laufen sondern muss im zweifelsfall das auch noch ein bisschen korrigieren
wenn der shooter zum erfolg werden soll und schnell sein und so genau sein sind wir bei den
flops die ubisoft in letzter zeit produziert und auch veröffentlicht ente moment sorry ente war
nicht ubisoft hätten wir zum einen hyperscape das war ja zwar ein bettel royale shooter der
2020 war die andere zwei genre eine eigene präsenz aufbauen wollte aber das hat augenscheinlich
nicht die waren viel zu spät die waren viel zu spät und irgendwie hat mich das spiel auch null
angesprochen waren die server so leer dass ubisoft die reißleine zu hyperscape hob sich von der
konkurrenz durch zwei aspekte ab zum einen betonte das futuristische level design eine vertikale
vorgehensweise die flotte matches provozieren sollte zum anderen legte ubisoft sehr viel wert
darauf seine bettel royale kreation mit twitch zu vermehlen über die streaming plattform
der die an sich an der plattform auf laufende partien nehmen oder durchs bloße anschauen von
hyperscape streams ihren bettel pass level trotz der zweifels ohne interessanten idee
ging hyperscape aber nie richtig viral auch spätere ich glaube das lag hauptsächlich
halt an dem game selbst nochmal das gameplay überarbeiten wollten konnten nicht den erhofften
effekt erzielen im april 2022 wurde das spiel eingestellt während hyperscape der bettel royale
formel hinterher hechtete war bei roller champions der erfolg von rocket ich wollte gerade sagen ist
das hier in den rocket league klohler hier jagen wir auf roller blades quer durch eine oval förmige
von diesem spiel habe ich seriously noch nie was gehört suchen einen ball in ein tor zu werfen
simples aber vielversprechendes spielkonzept mit potential für langfristige umsätze zumindest in
der theorie die ersten reaktionen auf das free to play spiel waren auch recht wohlwollend doch
schon kurz nach der veröffentlichung im mai 2022 verschwand roller champions in der bedeutungslosigkeit
offizielle spielerzahlen sind zwar nicht bekannt aber auf twitch bewegen sich die durchschnittlichen
zuschauerzahlen in den letzten monaten zwischen 70 und 120 das ist ja nichts das ja nichts kein
gutes zeichen für ein service spiel im sommer berichtete außerdem ein vermeintlicher insider
dass ubisoft äußerst unzufrieden wegen des ausbleibenden erfolgs von roller champions sei
sogar in der einstellung des projekts sei möglich hieß es da ubisoft selbst dementierte allerdings
die gerüchte und beteuerte dass man weiter am spiel arbeiten will erst anfang oktober erschien
mit weg des drachen eine neue saison mit neuen karten und weiter sprich mich auch nicht wirklich
an ehrlich gesagt champions also durchaus die chance ähnlich wie rainbow six sie zu einem hit zu
reifen wenn auch nicht kleineren rahmen also wenn überhaupt das kann mir nicht vorstellen das war
es ein kleiner überblick über die aktuellen oder auch schon abgeschlossenen problemprojekte
von ubisoft ein paar namen wie das remake von splinter cell oder auch das neue the division was
ein free to play ableger werden wird sind jetzt hier nicht mit dabei weil da noch nicht wirklich
klar ist wie laufen die projekte wird es da probleme geben also haben wir sie eher rausgelassen
läuft bei ubisoft gerne mal in den kommentaren schreiben welchen von diesen spielen ihr vielleicht
nachweint weil sie nicht umgesetzt wurden ehrlich gesagt keine gestellt wurden wenn ich mir das so
angucke nicht wirklich keine ich habe hunger leute glaube ich gehe jetzt was essen pepo fett mache ich
jetzt genug ist das ich gehe jetzt was futtern aber doch in jemanden hosten können wir könnten
den lost hosten was macht er denn war sonn monka es war sonn war ich jetzt net
aus gibt es noch klar oder rates alles aufs gleiche raus keine ahnung ich gehe jetzt einfach
auf jetzt heute noch spazieren weiß ich nicht scheiß wetter und es ist sonntag aber vielleicht
vielleicht wie gesagt sonntags bin ich ja meistens nicht so aktiv dafür jeden anderen
tag kann wo bloß hosten high iq gute idee sollte man machen ich hausse mich selbst
passiert eigentlich wenn ich mich selbst hauste es geht nicht leute man kann sich nicht selbst
hausen rate wo bloß du kannst ich nicht selbst raiden steht da habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
das ist ja doof man kann sich nicht selbst raiden ja recursive raiding alles klar wir
sehen uns leute bis denn zu